안녕하십니까, 채미선 여러분. 행복한
투자 예정을 함께하는 체슬리 모닝프
6월 23일 화요일 1부
시작하겠습니다.
어, 전일 중국 시장. 한국 시장은
어저께 어, 반도체 중심으로 아주
압축된 종목들이 좋은 장이었는데요.
중국 어땠는지 말씀 들어 보겠습니다.
>> 네. 요새는 그 지수 선물 옵션
만기일 때문에 상한 지수 플러스
1.8% 중 오고요. 흑슨테 지수는
-1.2% 2% 하락하고 정시 거대는
다시 3중 8조원까지 올라왔어요.
3중 8조 위안은 역사를 하면은 대충
800조 900조 됩니다. 거의 뭐
최근 최상등 가지고 올라왔어요.
업종별등 부시면 어제 소제 금융
산업제 업종이 강세부였고 반면은
자유소비제 유티케이션도 업종이
약세포였습니다. 다만 전세터는 다
올라갔고요. 종동 리스크 완화당으로
소재 관련주 어 급등했습니다. 정석
구리는 매너 플러스 3% 청자 리튬는
4.5% 중국 아르미늄은 5%
올라왔어요. 이쁜기 실적 기대감으로
2차 정지 관련주 어때도
반등했습니다. C티어는 자정 5%
올라고 이부 에너지를 5% 훔쳐
주시는 6% 올라왔어요. 어 충구
반도체 업체 정설 그리고 글루벌 등화
등 요으로 반도체 권용주 어제는 매우
강세를 불렀습니다. SMS는 3%
올라고요. 부평 화천는 3.3%
조이태그 구준 7% 정비 공사는
3.5% 5% 어 전전테크는 10%
정도 상한가 기록했습니다. 그리고
우리 잘 아는 그 장비주들이 부환
종리 공사는 다 역사는 신고됐습니다.
어 이쁜기 실적 기대감 그리고
광트레시버 출화 상승 조정도 요으로
광동신 권 관련주 어제도하고요. 종재
우차는 1.1%로 역사적 신고하고
종비 광는 광성미 회사했고요. 어제는
A주는 10% 정도 상한가 기록하지만
그 홍콩도 동시 상장 회사
급등했습니다. 어 그리고 정테크는
우증 5% 올라왔어요.
증시 거래대금 상승 저가 매수 자금
요육으로 금융주 어세도 급등했습니다.
종신 증권은 8% 동방 체포는 13%
중국 인수 포함은
5% 올라왔어요. 특히 신화는 10%
정도 상한가 기로했어요. 요리 선묘
공급 부조에 따라서 가격 추가 인상
기대감으로 총구선은 5.9%로 또
거의 상가 기록하고요. 중재 테크는
5% 올라왔습니다. 이외는 전역 기기
관련주도 강세 보였고요. 사원 테크는
우증 8% 요시 동료로 4% 길수시는
5% 올라왔어요. 반면은 에너지 유틱
파워주어 상대적 이쁘지 모습을
배웠습니다. 신념물 구세 금리 어제
염정 1bp 하라 했습니다. 세금에
염정 자비P 하라고 외화마 헌열는
염증 2%도 소포 잘화되었습니다.
감사합니다. 텍스트 써 주신 것 중에
어 여섯 번째 줄에
>> 네
>> 장비 광섬 + 10% 괄호 홍콩플 +
30은 홍콩하고 본토하고 같이 상장될
때 얘기네
>> 공상장입니다.음 음. 그럼 홍콩에서는
30% 올랐는데 본토에서는 상한가가
10%라 10%만
>> 그러면 오늘 또
>> 오르겠네.
>> 네. 무조건 수급 때문에 중심 좀비
권사는 차량 이슈 없으면은 20%
10%가도 바로 시작됩니다.
>> 음. [목을 가다듬음]
이게 보니까 상해 지수 어 선전 지수
그리고 CSI 300 전부 다 뭐 1
2% 이상 오르고 뭐 이런 거 좀
쉽게 잘 못 봤던 거 같은데. 어
어제는 뭐 지수 선물 관련해서 어떤
>> 그냥 단기 이벤트였다면 오늘은 좀
되돌립니까?
>> 맞아요. 그래서이 오늘 시장 잘 봐야
하고요. 오늘 시장 빠지면은 아마 그
어제는 오라는 거는 진짜 지소 선물
옵션 때문에 올라가는데요. 근데 오늘
추가적으로 올라가면은 또 아마 3월
20 나올 수 가능성이 있습니다.
>> 왜냐면 거래대금은 거의 3.8조까지
올라왔어요. 이런 거래대금 이거 자금
요입이는 쉽지 않아요. 보기. 음.
알겠습니다.
>> 예. 지수가 오랜만에 좀 크게
상승했는데요. 그러면 이슈 종목으로가
보겠습니다. 장전테크입니다. 저희
소개를 시켜 주셨던 종목인 거
같아요.
>> 아 아닙니다. 처음입니다. [웃음]
>> 이런 좀 비슷하니까 해갈 수
있습니다.
>> 어 전전 테크는이 시간 초에 37조
정도 되고요. 포드 피아는 63배
정도 되고 어제는 10% 상한가
기록했습니다.이 회자는 충고 대표적인
반도세 패키징인 테스트 호눈
기업고요. 이거 전비주 아니고요.
전에 발표할 회사는 정비 중입니다.
이거 그냥 순수 호공이고 군내는 대화
회사는 그냥 하나 마이클로 비타는
회사고요.
>> 어이 회사는 MS도 거의 12증 2%
포스트로 유지하고 있고 글로벌 3등
정도 되고요. 중구 시전는
2등입니다. 어 글로벌 1위 회사는
ASE 테크놀로지 홀딩스이고요.이
회사는 대만 회사입니다. 증세 MS는
22 5%을 차지하고 있고 그리고
전테크는 지금은 해외 매출 비조는
78% 정도 되고 중국 군에는 20%
정도 됩니다. 1분기 매출에는 동의는
-1.8% 감소하지만 수익는 동일
대비 42.7% 증가했어요. GP
마진 14.55% 나오고 어 동의
대비 1.92% 확대했습니다. MP
마주는 3%로 동의 0.85% %
화대하고요. 여기서 확신 부분 좀
보시면 GP 마진는 해외 지금 매수
비중는 78% 되지만 GP 마주는
해외는 12% 밖에 없어요. 중국
군는 20% 돼요.
>> 이거 다른 회사 좀 반대 현상을
나오고 있습니다.
>> 그래서이 현후는이 회사 충구 매출
비용 화대하면은 아마 증사 마진은
개선될 수 있습니다. 커마진 제품
매출 비중 화대 그리고 내거 지수도
전가 공정 가동률 상승으로 수위성은
개선되고 있습니다. 정 마케중으로
통신 정비는 32.4% 되고 정작
제품은 24% 연산은 20% 자동차
구조 6% 정도 되고요. 이종의 연산
매출는 도대비 42.증 % 증가하고
자동차는 플러스 31은 7% 증가하고
있습니다. GP은 리포트는 며칠 이틀
전에는 관련 리퍼 나왔습니다.에 관련
매출 거승전 공정 가동률 상승
ASP가 가격 상승으로 매수 의견을
제시했습니다.
어 2028년까지는 동산 A의 영양
영량 매출 비조는 지금 20%에서
40%까지 파될 가능성이 있어요.
GP 마진율 이부 인는 거의
28%부터 35% 중 됩니다. 어
정사 GP 마
수중이고요. 광 모듈딜 솔루션 영역도
화성이 있습니다. 동사 5월 그때는
100억 외한 정도 캠페스 투자
계획을 발표했어요. 2015년 대비는
25% 정도 증가했습니다. 장기간에
감가성과 부담종이 있어요. 그래서
최근에 주관는 조정하면 받았습니다.
다만 거 보가지 재출 비중 화대 공정
가동률 상승용으로 마진 개선이 시장
예상치 대비 상회 가능성 좀 있다고
얘기했습니다. 관련 수주 화대에
따라서 원래부터 내년 내후년 매출에는
각가 지전 대비 3% 8% 10%
정도 상승전했습니다. 순위는 각는
22억 위향 34억 위향 43억
위향으로 지정 대비는 1% 7%
13% 상형주 했고요. 내년 40배
적용해서 TP는 위엔 형시했습니다.
어이 회사는 2015년 하반 그대는
관영 디포드 하나 나왔어요. 그때
제시하는 목표 주가 대비는 144%
상승 조준했습니다. 어제 10%
선승하기 때문에 어 종가 대비 20%
없애 있습니다. 어 현구 인연 EPS
CGR 47%을 감안하면 지금 PH는
1등3배 수준입니다.음 음. 어,
제가이 기업을 잘은 모르지만 숫자 몇
개만 좀 챙겨보고 넘어갈게요. 위에
그 장전테크 제목써 있는 줄에 보면
>> PR이 63배라고 되어 있어요.
>> 네.
>> 그런데 맨 밑에 보면은 2027년
>> 40배 PR 적용해서 110p
제시 이렇게 되어 있는데
>> 네. 어 위에 시가 총액 써 있는
줄에 있는 포드 P 63대가
어 이게 아직 26년치
맞아요. 이거 왜냐면 지금 2분기 실
발표 지전 전에요. 그러면 2분기
3분기 4분기 그냥 내년 1분기 그
가방하면 나오는 포드 P이고
>> 어 그리고이 포드 P는 거는 시전
컨서스입니다. 밑에 거로 보시면은
GP모 추정한 추정치입니다.음요
음.요 밑에 표는 JP 모건에서
>> 제 발표한 추정치인데 맞네요. 좀
전에 제 왕부장님 말씀해 주신 대로
FI262라고
되어 있는 아직까지 이제 추정
예상치인데
>> 밑에 밸류에이션 밑에 쭉 내려보니까
>> 어스트 P라고 되어 있는데 이게 어떤
이제 조정 요인을고고 고려한 네
>> 어 PER 멀티플이 61.1배로 되어
있고 내년은 37.7배로 7배로 되어
있는데 내년도를 한 40배 정도로
적용했을 때 110이안. 그래서
>> 어 현재 가격 대비도 한 20% 정도
업사이드가 좀 있다.
>> 요게
>> 어 막 50배짜리 60배짜리 막
90배짜리 이런 거 보다가 40배짜리
보면 상대적으로 싸 보이는데
>> 네.
>> 음. 이게 순환 참조 개념이기
때문에이 업항을 보고 지금 이제
무상향으로 배팅한다 이렇게 봐야지
절대적으로 싸다 뭐 이런 건 아닌 거
같아요.
>> 네. [목을 가다듬음] 절대로 산 건
아니고요. 왜냐면 지금은 그 1등주
ASE 테크로지 홀딩스 회사가 어
포드피 30배후반
정도 되고요. 저도 하면 그 PG를
보니까 PG는 0.78배 78배
정도입니다.
>> SE AS SE 테크놀로지. 다만
AS 테크놀로지 이미 잘하고 있는 거
잘하고 있고요.이 회사가 이제보다는
거 맞는
진출하고 있습니다. 왜 연산은 지금
매출 비료는 20% 바뀌 없습니다.
대부분 다 내 것이요. BC
한드폰이고요. 그래서이 GP 마진
쪽으로 GP 마진율을 쪽으로 보시면
14% MP 마진률는 3%밖에
없어요. 그리고 한 가지도
있습니다.이
>> 회사가 케페스 투자는 계속 확대하고
있어요. 작년 작년도 80억 정도
하고 올해는 100억 정도 했어요.
그러면 현호는 내년 내 혼년 아마
추가적으로 가능성도 있어요.
추가적으로 화대가 가능성이 있습니다.
>> 그래서이 감가 상가는 아마 부담감이
계속 커질 수 있고 그래서이
강화선가 감하면은 순위는 잘 못 나올
수 가능성이 있어요. 그래서이 멀티브
세게 주고 있습니다.음
>> 알겠습니다. 마지막으로 좀 어리석은
질문일 수도 있는데 글로벌 마켓어가
12.2%라고 %라고 써 주셨어요.
>> 이게 어 해외에 있는 만약에 해외에
있는 중국 기업에 수출을 해도 수출로
잡힐 거 같은데
>> 네
>> 어 중국 기업입니까? 아니면 정말
해외에 중국 국적이 아닌 국가에게
수출하고 기업에게 수출하고 있습니까?
아 그 중국 기업으로 좀 보시면
되고요. 아네 왜냐면이 원래 그이
회사는 인수는 되게 많았어요. 분명히
군에 여기 군에 있는 회사가 두 개도
인수했어요.음
>> 한국 기업을 네네. 그래서 이거는
전진 코리아 이런 거 다 있어요.
공자 다 있고
>> 그 마진 나와요.
>> 음.
그러네. 지금 미국이 어 중국의
반도체 굴기, 기술 굴기를 지금
막으려고 애를 쓰고 있는데 어
진출이나 수출이 아닌 해외 기업
인수를 통해서
>> 음네. 네어조금씩 발을 넓히고 있는
그런 것들이 이렇게
>> 조금조금씩은 좀 보이는 모양입니다.
>> 저희가 계속 체크를 해야 한국의 지금
AI 중심의이 상승 사이클을 언제
어떻게 혹시 이게 사이클이 꺾일 때
>> 어 피할 수 있는지 단초를 좀 얻을
수도 있을 것 같아요. 네.
>> 그런 부분들 계속 체크하면서 중국
시장 같이 보도록 하겠습니다.
>> 네. 중국 시장 여기까지 보도록
하고요. 전일 미국 시장 어떻게
됐는지 우리 유리프로와 함께
알아보겠습니다.
어, 저는 이제 22일 월요일 미국장
말씀드리도록 하겠습니다. 우선
금요일의 휴장이었기 때문에 좀 어떻게
주가가 이동하는지를 노심초 하면서
계속 봐왔던 거 같은데요. 우선 지수
주요 지수부터 보시면은 다우하고 이제
러셀 2천 소폭 올랐는데 0.29%
% 0.83%
다만 이제 주목할 만한 점은 SMP
500은 하락을 했고요. 나스닥은
1% 넘게 빠졌습니다. 이제 반면
필라델피아 반도체 지수 혼자 이제
2.04% 오르면서 좀 돋보적인
움직임 보여줬습니다. 어제 장을 한
문장으로 표현하자면은 좀 돈을 쓰는
쪽 그리고 돈을 받는 쪽이 갈린
하루였다라고 말씀드릴 수 있을 것
같은데 여기서 돈을 쓰는 쪽은
스페이스엑스 알파벳, 구글, 아마존,
마이크로소프트처럼 AI 인프라 투자를
이제 계속 집행해야 되는 기업들일
거고요. 반대로 이제 돈을 받는 쪽은
마이크론이나 샌디스크, 웨스턴 디지털
같은 메모리나 스토리지 기업, 그리고
뭐 반도체 장비, 광 네트워크, 전력
인프라 기업들입니다. 그래서이
구분선이 더 뚜렷해진 하루였다라고 볼
수 있을 것 같습니다.
>> 아무래도 뭐 지금 시장의 센티 자체가
이미 뭐 데이터 센터, 서버, 전력,
뭐 모델 학습 비용 이렇게 비용이
계속 늘어날 수밖에 없다라는 좀
대전제가 좀 깔려 있습니다. 그래서
결국 빅테크 중에서도 누가이 막대한
투자비를 실제 수익으로 회수할 수
있을지가 관건일 텐데 여기에 이제
어제 미국 10년물 금리가 다시
4.5%를 넘어섰거든요. 그래서 어
금리가 또 다시 휴먼 인덱스로 휴먼
인덱스 4.5%를 넘어선 상황에서이
성과 회수에 시간이 걸리는
기업들한테는 더 부담이 커진
상황이다라고 볼 수 있을 것
같습니다. 이제 이런 상황에 아무래도
이제 불을 지혔던게 스페이스 X
언급할 수밖에 없을 것 같은데요.
스페이스엑가 이제 어제 16% 넘게
하락했고 3거래 연속 하락하면서
IPO 상장 당일보다 시가 총액 간로
이상을 반납했습니다. 이제 주가도
상장 첫날 이후에 지금 가장 낮은
수준까지 내려왔고요. 이제 월요일
장전부터 사실 하락하고 있기는
했었습니다. 그래서 한 왜 그럴까를
좀 나눠서 생각해 보면 한 세 가지
이유 정도로
>> 볼 수 있을 것 같은데 일단 어제 한
16% 넘게 너무 큰 폭을 이제
하락한 핵심은 아무래도 자금 조달
부담이었던 거 같습니다. 스페이스
X가 최소한 20빌리언 규모의 투자
등급에 이제 회사체 발행을 추진하고
있다라는 이제 이슈가 전달 알려졌는데
사실이 회사체 발행권에 대해서는
지난주부터 좀 알려지긴 했었거든요.
그래도 이게 월요일에 장이 열리면서
다시 가장 큰 부담으로 작용한 것으로
보입니다.
>> 근데 여기서 이제 중요한 점은 그
회체를 왜 발행을 할까라는 점일 거
같은데 현금이 없어서 돈을 빌리는 건
아니거든요. 그 보도 기준으로 보면은
스페이스가 지금 100빌리언 넘는
현금을 보유하고 있는데 이제 그럼에도
불구하고 회사체를 발행하는 이유는 아
써야 될 것이 그만큼 정도를 해석을
해 볼 수 있을 것 같습니다. 뭐
앞전에도 저희 공모주 분석하고
부사장님 말씀도 계속 하시긴 했는데
우선은 XAI 인수 과정에서 발생한
20빌리언 규모의 이제 브릿지론 임시
단기 대출이죠. 이거를 장기 회사로
갈아타는 그 차는 해야 되거든요.
그래서 만기가 짧은 대출을 그대로
두기보다는 이걸 장기 회사로 바꾸면은
당장 이제 상황부담을 뒤로 미를 수
있다는 장점이 있어서 이걸 수행할
것으로 보이고
이제 또 동시에 스페이스엑스는
스타십을 개발을 해야 되잖아요.
그리고 위성 네트워크 AI 인프라
데이터 센터 이런 컴퓨팅 투자까지
모두 진행을 해야 되는 상황입니다.
그래서 AI 인프라 같은 경우는
초기에 현금이 크게 들어가지만 계속
말씀드렸듯이 실제 수익으로
횟수되기까지 시간이 되게 오래 걸리기
때문에 어 시장이 뭐 현금이 지금
100빌리 넘게 있어도 정말 충분한
거. 스페이스 X에게 그리고이 투자가
과연 그렇다면 언제 현금으로 돌아올
수 있을 것인가를 더 주목하기 시작한
거 같습니다.
>> 음.
>> 스크롤를 안 내렸네요. 네. [웃음]
네. 그래서 이제 뭐 계속 말씀드리고
있지만 또 AI 수요가 그래서
꺾였냐? 또 그렇다기보다는 AI를
하려면은 너무 많은 돈을 먼저 써야
한다는 점에 스페이스 X가 다시 지금
기름을 좀 끼어진 상황이 아닌가라고
이제 보여집니다. 이런
[목을 가다듬음] 자금 조달 부담이
사실 스페이스엑스만의 문제는 아니긴
합니다. 뭐 알파벳이나 아마존 오라클
같은 기업들도 AI랑 이제 클라우드
인프라 투자를 위해서 대규모
현금흐름을 계속 써야 되기 때문에
빅테크 쪽의 중간에 보시면은
그 빅테크 쪽에도 다 파란불이거든요.
빅도이 현금 조달에 좀 부담감 이런
분위기를 계속 전달한 것으로
보입니다.
>> 회사체 발행 또 그리고 금리에도 사실
영향을 줄 수도 있습니다. 대규모
회사체가 나오면 투자자들이 그
회사체를 이제 싹 살려고 기존 국채
아니면 다른 채권을 팔 수도
있잖아요. 그래서 이걸 발행하는
과정에서 또 금리 해지하려는 수요도
생깁니다. 그래서 어제 금리 신년물이
왜 4.5%를 5%를 다시
넘어갔을까를 생각을 해보면은 이게 뭐
전부 스페이스 X가 다 하락해서 다
지수 하락한 것도 스페이스 X
때문이다라고 이제 단정지울 수
없겠지만은 이제 AI 이런 관련된
기업들의 대규모 회사 발행이 채권
시장의 수급 부담을 좀 키우면서이
부담이 다시 성장 밸루에이션을 좀
누르는 구조에도 기여하지 않았을까
정도로 생각을 해 볼 수 있을 것
같습니다. 또 마지막으로 그냥 유통
물량이 적었던 점도 함께 짚을 수
있을 것 같은데 우선은 가장
핵심적이었던 거는요 AI 인프라
투자에 대한 부담이 가장 크지
않았을까로 이제 볼 수 있을 것
같습니다. 이제 반대로 다시 반대급
포인 존을 받는 쪽으로 이동해
보시면은 반도체 쪽이죠. 아무래도
이쪽은 좀 강했습니다.요 흐름이
ETF 쪽에서 저 확인되는데 이게
블룸모그 보도한 기사를 제가 읽으면서
좀 생각을 해 봤던 건데 저 국내에서
지금 계속 말씀드리고 있는게 그
라운드일 메모리 디램 ETF죠.요 요
디레미티가 월요일 장초반에 5%
가까이 올랐고 이게 4월 달에 출시가
됐거든요. 근데 그 이후에 190%
상승을 했습니다. 그래서 기존에는 좀
AI 투자를 이제 넓게 갖고 가려면은
뭐 속스라든지 아니 SMH 같은
반도치 전반적인 ETF를 갖다면은
이제는 뭐 확실히 이제 시장이 AI
인프라의 다음 구간을 메모리로 보고
디램미 ETF처럼 좀 집중된 상품을
찾는 흐름이 나타나고 있는 것으로
보입니다.
여기에는 또 불을 집힌 요소들이 계속
나타나고 있는데 또 마이크로 실적이
이제 이번 주에 또 있고요. 그
시장이 HBM 수요라든지 메모리 가격
그리고 AI 서버양 가이던스 이제
확인하려고 할 거고 또 SK 하이닉스
미국 상장 가능성도 이제 계속 추진이
되고 있고 그래서 이게 현실화
된다면은 이제 미국 투자자들이 AI
핵심 공급 없이 좀 직접 적당할 수
있는 통로가 생긴다는 점도 기여가 될
거고요. 그 메모리 이제 업항
자체에도 좀 긍정적인 리포트가
나왔습니다. 프리스가 월요일에 이제
방중에 발표를 했는데 이게 3분기 좀
파격적인 리포트였습니다. 3분기 이제
메모리 가격이 전분기 대비 40에서
50% 4분기에도 추가로 이제 3,
40% 상승할 수 있다라고 봤고 특히
이제 클라우드 서비스 사업자들이 한
40% 선지급 조건으로 장기 공급
계약 체결하고 있어서 메모리 공급이
서버랑 AI 쪽으로 배분되고 있다.
그래서 마이크론이랑 하이닉스는 좀
우호적인 이제 상황이 계속 펼쳐지고
있고 또 추가적으로 이제 어제
마이크론이 엔트로픽하고 전략적인 이제
계약 파트너십을 발표를 했습니다.
이제 엔트로피 이제 클로드라는 LLM
모델이 있는데이 확장을 위해서 주요
메모리 그리고 스토리지들을 공급할
거고 그리고 AI 인프라 설계
단계에서부터 함께 최적화하겠다 맞춰
가겠다라는 내용을 발표를 했습니다.
이제 그래서 이게 이제 마이크론 한
어제 7% 가량 상승했는데 좀 귀여운
것으로 보이고요. 그리고 또 이제
계속 지난주부터 상승세 이어가고 있는
반도체 장비주들도 계속 신고가 이름을
올렸습니다. 어플라이드 머티리스라든지
램리서치 KL 같은 장비주도 강했고
그리고 계속 이제 좀 지난주에는
빠지고 있었던 관련 섹터들도 이제
하단에 보시면은 루맨턴 코일런트
시에나도 이제 다 이제 동반 상승을
했습니다. 그 마지막으로 좀 특기
드리고 싶은 점은 아날로그 반도체에도
좀 이제 업한 기대라고 제가 마지막에
텍스트로 기재를 해 드렸는데 이제 뭐
텍 그 좀 전통적인 반도체라고 할 수
있는 텍사스 인스트로먼트 같은 경우가
이제 3% 마량 올랐거든요. 어,
다만 이게 뭐 AI 수회다라고 또
이게 극단적으로 극단적이라고 딱 그
단일 이유로 꼽기는 어렵긴 할 텐데
그래도 이게 뭐 AI 데이터 센터
전력 관리 신호 처리될뿐 아니라 뭐
산업용이라든지 다 자동차 이런
광범위하게 전통 안 하려고 반도체
업항들도 바다가 지나고 있다.
그들까지 이제 좀 기가 확산되고 있다
정도로 볼 수 있을 것 같습니다.
>> 어. 네. 그래서 어제 또 랩업을 또
드리자면은 앞으로는 뭐 AI 투자가
계속된다라는 팩트도 중요하긴 하지만
그 투자가 누구한테 비용이고 누구한테
이제 매출이 될 건가 관건이 될 거
같습니다. 플랫폼 기업들이 계속
금리가 4.5% 수준에서 뭐 설비
투자 부담 그리고 회사 발행에 따른
자금 조달 비용 그 핵심인제 방어력
그에서 제가 또 언급을 살짝 드리긴
했는데 구글이 5% 빠졌던게 핵심인제
C레벨의 리스크 이탈 리스크가
있었거든요. 그래서 이제 이런 걸로
봤을 때 뭐 계속 이제 그 케펙스들이
투자 대비해서 회수 가능한가 이렇게
계속 검증을 받을 수밖에 없습니다.
반대로 이제 메모리라든지 스토리지
장비 이런 인프라 업체들은 실제 수주
그리고 가격 결정력이 이어지는지 이거
관건일 것 같고요. 그래서 이번 주에
특히 마이크론 실적 발표가 있기
때문에요 메모리 랠리 지속 여부 가를
것으로 이제 보이고 그래서 AI
수요가 있느냐 없느냐가 아니라이
사이클 안에서 누가 현금을 태우고
누가 그 태운 만큼을 갖고 가느냐를
확인하는게 핵심이 될 것 같습니다.
이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다. 미국이 연초 이후에 SP
500 나스닥 10% 내외 지수가
상승 중인데 밑에 보시면 뭐 M7
또는 뭐 빅테크라고 볼 수 있는 그런
한 열 개 남지세 기업들이 보면 어
10% 정도 오른 뭐 구글이나
애플이나 엔비디아 어 브로드컴 이런
것도 있지만
>> 뭐 두 자릿수 이상으로 하락한
종목들도 많고
>> 이러다 보니까
>> 어 불과 한 수개월 전에 마켓
브로드닝이라는 단어들을 저희가 많이
접할 수 있었던 거 같아요. 시총
상위 종목들이 그냥 지지부진하면서
중형주 또는 소형주단으로 이렇게 좀
어 매기가 확대되면서음
>> 급등하는 종목들이 나오기 시작했는데
이제 마켓 브러드닝이란 말은 쓸 수
없을 것 같아요. 그렇죠? 이게 아주
극히 일부 종목들만 오르니까
>> 전일 한국 시장도 그랬지만 미국
시장도
>> 일부 종목들 말씀 유리프로가 말씀해
주신 것처럼 지금 당장 돈을 좀 받는
쪽만 오르고 [콧방귀] 있어서 시장
전반적으로는 센티먼트가 좋지 않은 건
맞는 거 같습니다. 어쨌 최부
사장님도 그래서 그리디앤 피어
인덱스가 피어 영역이 있다고 말씀해
주셨는데 다 같이 좀 오르고 또
그중에서도 주도가 좀 더 오르고 이런
장이 와야 할 텐데 그렇지 않으면 그
끝은 조금 더
안 좋지 않을까?
예. 그 이제 걱정을 좀 하면서 미국
시장 유리프로의 말씀을 좀
들어봤습니다.
>> 예. 다음 가상자산으로 넘어가야 될
텐데요. 우리 가상자산 대신 오늘
준비해 주신 자료는 공모주인가 봐요.
>> 네. 국내 그 매드업이라는 기업이
상장 예정이라서 어 7월 1일 날
상장 예정이고 지금 개인 투자는
오늘부터 해 가지고 지금 청약을
진행하고 있습니다. 우선 그전에
가상자산 관련해서 간단한 코멘트
하나만 한번 드리면 가상자산이 다시
한번 6만6,000불 정도 구간을
도전하다가 지금 저항을 막고 어 지금
63,000불 정도 때까지 다시 한번
저항을 맞고 지금 저장을 받고
있는데요. 가장 큰 이유는 지금
3호시장 리스크가 지금부터 다시
내려가고 있다. 이렇게 생각하시면 될
거 같습니다. 어제 아폴로 관련된
뉴스가 나왔었는데 아폴로에서 그
사모시장 환매하려고 하는 요청이
17% 정도가 나왔거든요. 근데
대부분 그 환매 요청을 받아주는
케이스가 5% 정도의 어 국한이 돼
있다 보니까 그 5% 제한 근데
17% 정도 요청이 왔었다. 이런
뉴스 때문에 지금 어제 IGB도 약간
어 하락하는 모습 그니까 소프트웨어
그 ETF도 같이 폭락하는 모습을
보여줬고 그리고 해당 어 섹터가 같이
붙어서 많이 가는 비트코인도 좀
하락하고 있다. 이렇게 보시면 될 것
같습니다. [콧방귀] 매드업으로 다시
돌아가세요. 어, 매드업은 AI 기반
광고 대응하고 그 디지털 마케팅
솔루션을 하는 기업이다라고 보시면 될
거 같습니다. 어, 사업 개우 쪽을
먼저 보시면 되는데요. 어, 25년
기준으로 마케팅 사업 부분 가장 위에
있는 부분이 76% 정도 되다 보니까
마케팅 사업 부분이 거의 본체인
회사이다. 이렇게 보시면 될 거 같고
그 밑에 있는 솔루션 사업 부분을
이따 조금 주목해서 말씀을 드릴
건데이 부분에서 어 매출 비중이
커지면 커질수록 어 매드업의 그 매출
구조랑 이런 뭐 매출 믹스나 이런
부분들이 좋아질 수밖에 없는 어 그런
좋은 어 엔진을 갖고 있습니다. 어
그런 부분 주목해서 보시면 될 거
같습니다. 어 내려서 보시면
브레이크다운을 좀 간단하게 해
놨습니다. 처음에 마케팅 사업이 한
106% 정도가 되고요. 어 전통적인
디지털 광고 대응을 하고 있습니다.
그래서이 회사 갖고 있는 레버
익스퍼트라는 엔진이 하나 있는데 이거
이런 것들을 활용해서 조금 더
효율적으로 광고할 수 있게 대형 광고
대행사를 대형 광고 어 대행을 좀
맡아서 진행하고 있다라고 보시면 될
거 같고 어 저 광고비 집행에게
11%에서 15% 정도를 수치하고 그
추가적으로 인센티브까지 받는 그런
사업 구조 어 전가 그냥 알고 있는
그런 사업 구조를 갖고 있다. 그리고
여기서 거의 다 캐시가 나온다 이렇게
해석하시면 될 거 같고요. 어,
삼성금융 계열사 그리고 올리브행
무신사 메디 등을 고객을 두고
있다라고 하니까 그리고 대형 어 광고
업체들, 대형 그리고 소비 업체들 어
이런들 이런 기업들을 고객으로 두고
있다 생각해 주시면 될 것 같습니다.
어, 두 번째 솔루션 서업에 제가
하이라이트를 처리해 놨는데요. 자체
개발한 레벨 엑스라는 것들을 외부
고객 어, 인하우스 마케팅이 될 수도
있고 타인사가 될 수도 있고 그리고
사스 형태로 직접 판매가 된다라고
합니다. 전이 문장에 가장 인상이
깊었는데 어 다른 회사 마케팅 팀
인하우스에다가 솔루션을 제공하는 그런
업체입니다. 그래서 마케팅 업체에 또
다른 마케팅 솔루션 할 수 있게 어
그런 어 엔진을 제공하는 그런
업체다라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
어 연동 광고비 규모에 따라서 59만
원에 38 389만 원의 구간별
구동료가 어 그 징수가 되고요.
미디엄 결합시 매체사로부터 광고비
1%에서 5%까지 인센티브를
추가적으로 수치하게 됩니다. 어,
인력 투입을 좀 최소화하고 매출
확대가 가능한 고마진 구조입니다.
이게 엔진을 한번 그냥 제공을 하는
거기 때문에 그냥 사스에 대한 비용이
계속해서 반복적으로 지킬 수 있고
이제 영업 레버리지로 작용할 수 있는
그런 중요한 사업부다라고 보시면 될
거 같습니다. 그래서 점점 마케팅
사업부 쪽에 비중이 줄어들고 솔루션
사업부 쪽에 비중이 늘어나면
늘어날수록 어 캐시가 점점 반복적으로
더 레버리지 효과가 있을 것이다라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 브랜드
빌드업이라는 파트도 있는데요. 브랜드
가치 성장 삼재력을 발휘하지 못하는
어 브랜드를 직접 인큐베이팅하는 어
그런 브랜드입니다. 그래서 이거는 어
지속적으로 나오는 매출이다라기보다는
프로젝트 있을 때마다 어 점진적으로
찍혀 가는 그런 브랜드라 그런
사업보다라고 제가 해석을 했고요. 어
레버 익스퍼트가 그럼 뭐냐라고 보시면
될 거 같은데 디지털 마케터가 하는
일을 사람 대신 수행하는 AI
엔진입니다. 그래서 단순히한테
15시보드만 보여주는 어 B툴 그니까
비즈니스 인텔리전스 툴이 아니라 어
데이터 수집부터 분석 소재 그리고
제작 그리고 매체 운영 예산
최적화까지 진행하는 마케터의 실점을
처음부터 끝까지 자동화로 수행을 하게
됩니다. 어 디지털 대응의 비용
구조가 인건비 플러스 인권비성 경비가
약 80%를 차지를하고 있기 때문에
그 반복적이고 수작업 중심인 업무들을
AI를 통해서 효율적으로 만든다라고
합니다. 어, 논문으로 기술력도
입증을 받았고 실제 사람 마케터보다
뛰어난 효율성을 보여줬다라는 그런
분석 결과도 있다라고 하니까 꽤
증명이 많이 된 부분이다라고 보시면
될 거 같고요. 각종 광고 노출
매개차들은 클로드 API로 융이 되기
때문에 외부 통합 분석이 어렵다라고
합니다. 그래서이 문장이이 아까 제가
위에 하이 쳐 놓은 인건비 플러스
인권비성 경비가 80% 차지한다.
여기는 사실 괴를 같이 하는
문장인데요. 어 뭐 예를 들어서
구글에도 광고를 할 수 있고 메타에도
광고를 할 수 있고 스냅이나 다양한
어 SNS 플랫폼을 통해서 광고 매
광고를 할 수가 있는데 거기서
요구하는 마케팅 폼 또는 광고 노출
폼이 다르다고 합니다. 그래서 이런
것들을 다 어 직접 일일이 다 맞춰
줘야 되기 때문에 그런 것들 때문에
인건비 그리고 인건비성 경비가 굉장히
그 그 디지털 광고 쪽에서 차지하는
비중이 굉장히 컸다라고 하는데 그
비용 구조를 조금 어 효율할 수 있는
것들이 어 이분은 매드업이 갖고 있는
레벨 익스퍼트다 이렇게 보시면 될 거
같고요. 레드업은이 레벨 익스포트를
좀 발전시키기 위해서 적거래도 R&D
비용을 10% 15%를 유지하면서 전
처리 작업 그리고 결합 후처리 작업
그리고 내부 도민 지직전 지직
적용하는 파이프라인까지 구축을
했다라고 합니다. 그래서 이레버
엑스를 어 계속해서 발전시키는 과정
속에서 결국 디지털 광고 대응을 하고
있는 회사잖아요. 그래서 그 디지털
광고 있는 하고 있는 그 노아우드를
레벨 익스에 계속해서 도입을 해
줬다라고 보시면 될 거 같고 그
엔진은 거기다 그 레버리지로서 어
조금 더 효율화시킬 수 있는 그런
부분들을 계속해서 레드업시켜 주면서
지금까지 발전해 왔다라고 보시면 될
거 같습니다. 벌써 2015년에
창립한 회사고 18년부터 레벨 엑스
관련된 내용들이 계속해서 얘기했다
보니까 거의 8년 9년 동안 레벨
익스터의 힘을 많이 쏟았다라고 보시면
될 거 같고이 레벨 익스퍼트를
도입한게 24년인데 25년부터 흑자
전환을 했거든요. 그래서 레벨
익스퍼트가 아 효과가 있구나라는 거를
어느 정도 인정하면서 가고 있는
구간이다. 이렇게 보시면 될 것
같습니다. 그러면 이제 저희가 엠러빈
그 그 광고 에드테크에서는 엠러빈이
가장 어 대장주다라고 볼 수 있을 것
같은데 엠러빈의 엑선이라는 엔진이
지금까지 어이 엘러빈을 엠러빈 주가를
이끌어 왔는데요. 엠러빈의 엑은 사실
그 경매의 사이에 껴 있는
엔진이다라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
그래서 광고가 필요한 사람 광고를
해야 되는 사람 그 사이에 껴서 어
조금 경매를 좀 효율적으로 할 수
있게 그렇게 연결을 해줬던 기업이 그
엠로벤의 엑이다라고 보면 어 지금
매드업의 레벨 익스퍼트는 어 외부
광고 플랫폼을 통합 운용하는 AI
마케팅 오퍼레이션 엔진에 가깝다라는
한 주평이 좀 더 잘 어울릴 것
같습니다. 그래서이 광고 광고가
필요한 사람과 광고를 이어 주는게
아니라 그냥 광고 자체를 그냥
오퍼레이션 해 주는 어 그런 레 그
엔진이다라고 보시는게 레벨 익스퍼트가
가장 적절할 것 같습니다. 어
내려와서 보시면 그 밑에 있는 거는
그 논문이었고요. 밑에 내려와서
보시면 유통 물량부터 체크를 하시면
될 거 같습니다. 어 유통 물량
양호합니다. 양호하면 양호하다 보시면
될 거 같은데 가장 아쉬운 건 기존
주주의 물량이 굉장히 많습니다. 그
밑에 유통액 물량부터 보시면 되는데
어 기존 주주이 공모 주주 이번에
모아 모아서 하는 건 10% 정도밖에
안 되지만 기존 주주의 물량이 20%
가까이가 되게 됩니다. 그래서 유통
가능 물량이 총 30% 정도가
된다라고 보시면 될 거 같고 유통물
30% 정도는 그냥 무난하다. 너무
좋지도 않지만 너무 나쁘지도 않은
그런 수치다라고 보시면 될 거 같은데
하나 여기 힌트 그 트릭이 하나
있습니다. 가장 위에 쪽 보시면 여기
1개월 의무 제한 그 유통 물량 제한
걸려 있는 어이 13% 정도의 물량이
또 있거든요. 그래서 한 달 정도
있다가는 그 락업 물량이 해제되면서
어 굉장히 수급적으로 압박을 받을 수
있는 구조에 있다. 그런 그런
기업이다라고 보시면 될 거 같고요.
내어서 보시면 자금의 사용 계획을 어
매업에 올려줬습니다. AI 투자 AI
설비 투자 및 운영비 쪽으로 어 한
21억 정도 어 투입하겠다라고 말을
해 줬고 어 가장 밑에 쪽 보시면
미국 현지법인 출자 및 운용 비용이
있습니다. 그래서 지금 매도업이
하고자 하는 거는 국내에서 하고 있는
광고 시장보다도 어 미국 쪽이나 어
더 광고 시장이 큰 쪽으로 사업
진출을 하면서 그쪽에서 직접 사업을
진출하겠다. 그래서 거기서 조금 더
어 롱테일 기 그 기업들을 잡아서
계속해서 광고 서비스를 하겠다라고
지금 밝혀 주고 있는 것이고 26년에
가장 많은 비용 투입하고 27년
28년 전진적으로 인건비 운영 경비를
투입하게 된다라고 언급을 해 준 부분
확인하실 수 있을 것 같습니다. 실적
테이블이 유진 투자 정권에서 나온
사료가 있어서 가져왔습니다. 결국에
지금 2025년부터 어 영업 이익이
흑자로 돌아선 이것을 확인하실 수가
있을 것 같은데 이것이 계속해서
애드업에서 영업 레버리지로 작용해 갈
수 있다라는 부분을 계속해서 언급을
회사에서도 하해 주고 있고 연관인들
통해서도 내주고 있습니다. 이게
공무주들이 대부분 실적이 안다고 있는
기업들이 많기 때문에 어 조금 실적을
25년 온기 기준으로 점검한다던가
밸루에이션 기준을 어 50 25년
기준으로 그러니까 미래 것이 아니라
지금 현재 벌고 있는 것을
밸루에이션을 적용해서 조금 할인한
다음에 공모를 하는 경우가 굉장히
많은데요. 매더 같은 경우에도 지금
밸루에이션 자체를 할인을 하는 제가
방금 말씀드린 온기를 어 온기 이번
년도 얼마 벌었냐 그러니까 작년
기준으로 얼마 벌었냐 그리고 25년
밸루에이션에서 그니까 26년
밸루에이션 조금 약간 할인한 부분
이런 부분을 통해서 밸루에이에이션을
진행하긴 하지만 어쨌든 애드업은 지금
흑자 전환을 했고 어 26년
27년까지도 계속해서 흑자로 어
운영할 수 있는 것을 보여주고
있습니다. 그래서 어 유진투자 정권의
실적 테이블에 따르면 영업 이익이
지금 85억 정도에서 120억 그리고
230억 220억 200억 정도까지
어 점프업하는 부분을 어 계속해서 어
언급을 해 주고 있고요. 지금 광고
테크 에드테크 쪽들 밸류에이션을 보면
한 20배에서 10배 한 후반 정도가
다 형성이 많이 되어 있더라고요.
그래서 순위익이 곱해 보면 한 2,억
2,500억 정도 밸류 정도를 받을
수 있지 않을까 하는 생각을
개인적으로 하고 있습니다. 물론
이대로 나온다라고 하면 그렇지만
결국에 솔루션 사업부 매출이 가장
많이 나오는게 중요하기 때문에 그
부분이 나오는지 못 나오는지를 좀 잘
시켜 보시면 좋을 것 같다라는 생각을
하고 있고요. 뷰를 내려오셔서 보시면
그 유진투자 정권의 동일한 리포트에서
밸루에이션 나온 자료가 있었습니다.
그래서 평균 PER이 어 지금
에드테크 기업들 그리고 애드 그 광고
대응하는 기업들이 평균적으로 한
24배 정도가 되는데 여기서 한
30% 정도를 할인해서 아 11배
정도에서 공부가 8,000원 정도에
형성이 됐다라고 언급을 해
주셨는데요. 예상 시가 총액은 어제
보무가 확정이 됐기 때문에
1,500억 원으로 확정이 되었고요.
제가 아까 말씀드린 것처럼 어 한
당년 벌 수 있는 순익이 한 120억
정도 되니까 120억에다가 어 저희가
뭐 피해 한 20배 정도 간단하게
준다라고 하면 어 예상 시가 총액이
한 어 2,500억 정도 2,400억
정도 나올 수 있지 않나 그렇게
된다라고 하면 60% 정도의
업사이드는 남아 있는 거거든요.
그래서 공무가가 그래도 어 공무가
상단에 있는 것도 그렇고 기관 어
수요 예측을 했을 때 그 경구
경쟁률이 한 1400대 1 정도
됐었습니다. 그래서 그런 부분들
반영했을 때는 어 굉장히 조금
성공적인 공모주가 되지 않을까 하는
생각은 개인적으로 하고 있고요.
그렇게 된다라고 투자 포인트 여러
가지를 한번 살펴봐야 될 것
같습니다. 첫 번째는 영업
레버리지입니다. 아까 말씀드린
것처럼이 레버 그 레버 엑스퍼트를
통해서 계속해서 사업을 어 영유해
오고 있었는데 24년부터 본격적으로
도입하고 나서부터 흑자 전환을 하고
있고 영업 익률이 개선되고 있다라는
점을 회사 측에서도 그렇고 계속해서
언급을 해 주고 있고요. 어 아까
말씀드린 것처럼 회사 그 해외 시장이
진출하고 있습니다. 미국 시장이
압도적으로 더 크다 보니까 미국
시장에 있는 현지 광고주들을 좀
타깃을 해서 계속해서 사업을 하려고
하하고 있고 이렇게 된다라고 하면
나중에는 수출 비중이 좀 더
올라가면서 어 회사의 그 믹스가 좀
더 개선되고 영업 이익률이 올라가는
그런 그림까지 저희가 살펴볼 수 있지
않을까는 생각을 하고 있는데 단기간
내에 저희가 볼 수 있는 그림은 아닌
거 같습니다. 그래서 27년 28년
정도 되죠. 돼 줘야 이제 막 법인을
어 설립을 하고 진행을 하고 있는
거기 때문에 나중에 어떻게 될지 좀
지켜봐야 되는 2번은 조금 투자
포인트가 약하다라고 보시면 될 거
같고요. 세 번째는 성장 중인
취급입니다. 이거는 현재 진행형인
투자 포인트인데요. 치유고가 굉장히
높아지고 있습니다. 그 CAGR이 한
50% 정도 취급 기준으로는 나오고
있는데이 취급 취급가 매출이라고
보시면 안 되고요.이 이 광고 자체의
사이즈다라고 보시면 될 거고 거기서
이제 그 아까 말씀드린 것처럼 광고
대응업이다라고 하면 15% 정도 어
가져올 수 있는 그런 그림이다라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 그래서 광고
그 매드업이 지금 익스포저가 있는 그
트위코 자체가 사이즈가 점점 커지고
있다라는 점은 굉장히 고무적이고
시장에서 차지하고 있는 그 마켓가
3.6% 정도 되거든요. 그 부분도
CAGR 상태로는 어 2018년부터
한 33% 이상 나오고 있다라고
하니까 마켓을 계속해서 꾸준하게
증가를 시켜 가고 있는 그런 회사다.
이렇게 투자 포인트 세 개를 정리해
볼 수가 있을 것 같습니다. 그래서
결론은 말씀드리면 될 것 같습니다.
매드업은 광고 단승 광고 대행사를
넘어서 엔진을 통해서 그 레벨
엑스퍼트를 통해서 퍼포먼스 마케팅
업무를 자동화하는 AI 마케팅
기업입니다. 그래서 어 사람의 손이
많이 들어가는 그런 광고 대행업을 어
지금 좀 효율로 하고다 하는 AI
마케팅 기업이고요. 현재는 증가하는
마케팅 대응 사업이 주도를 하고
있지만 어 밸루에이션은 향후 그
솔루션 사업 그리고 그 그리고 AI
매니저 서비스 의해서 좌우될
것이다라고 말씀드릴 수가 있을 것
같고요. 어 자체 엔진 레벨 엑스를
활용하여서 레 영업 레버리지 가속화를
보여줬다는 점. 그래서 300 그
2025년은 350억 매출에
2024년에 350억 매출에 영업
이익이 -4억이었는데 어 2025년에
됐을 때 502억으로 매출이 뛰었고
그다음에 영업 이익이 어 85억까지
올라왔다 보니까 흑자전을 확하면서
상장을 상장을 돌입했다 이렇게 보시면
될 거 같고요. 실제 도입이 레벨
익스터가 2024년 7월이었는데
2025년 흑자 전환했고 솔루션
사업부의 성장 아까 말씀드린 레벨
익스퍼트를 파는 어 솔루션 사업부의
성장이 1분기에 121% YI를
보여줬기 때문에 향후 실적 기대감이
계속 존재하는 것은 사실이다라고
말씀드릴 수 있을 것 같습니다. 유동
물량이 30% 초반인 것은
고무적이지만 1개월 후에 바로 14%
락업이 해제되는 점은 단기적인 흐름이
좋고 중장기적으로는 실적으로 계속
증명해 나가면서 물량을 소호하는
시간을 갖춰야 된다라고 결론 지을 수
있고 마지막 리스크로는 국내 기업들
위주의 포트폴리오 및 광고 채널들은
양날의 검으로 작용할 수 있습니다.
그래서 현재 해외쪽 매출이 아예 없기
때문에 어 밸류에이션 대한
밸류에이션에 대한 우구심을 지우기
위해서는 해외 법인 쪽 고객들 고객
및 관련 매출을 좀 늘려갈 필요가
있다. 이렇게 안내를 드릴 수가 있을
것 같고 단기적으로 아까 말씀드린 건
좀 상장하고 나서는 지금 기관 쪽의
수요도 굉장히 좋고 기관 쪽도 우리가
확약을 하서 확약을 하면서이 매드업을
공무를 참여하고 싶다. 한 27%
정도가 그렇게 응답을 했다라고
하거든요. 그래서 어 단기적으로는
공무가 상단에 있는 것도 굉장히
고무적이고 기관들의 인기가 굉장히
좋은 거 그리고 유통 물량이 30%
정도에 머무른다라는 점은 굉장히
긍정적이지만 이거는 좀 단기자
단기간으로 반짝할 수 있는
공모주다라는 식으로 저희가 마무리를
지을 수 있을 것 같습니다.
이상입니다.
>> 감사합니다. 광고 시장이 예전에는
TV, 라디오 뭐 신문 이런데 이제
광고를 하게 되고 그런 이제 TV
라디오 신문 같은 전통 매체 광고하는
광고 패스들이 이제 수십년 어쩌면
100년 이상 쭉 공고의하면서 전
세계적인 글로벌 기업 그리고
한국에서도 두 세 개 기업들이
압도적으로 큰 대형사를 성장을 했다가
이후에 이제 뭐 인터넷 생기고 온라인
마케팅 생기고 이러면서 이제
소프트웨어를 이용해서 그런 온라인
마케팅도 하고 타겟 마케팅도 하는
회사들이 어 나오면서 상대적으로론
종소형이지만 계속해서 마켓어 가져가고
수익상도 확보하는 기업들이 나왔는데
오늘 준역주임님이
설명해 주신이 매드업이라는 회사를 쭉
듣다 보니까 어 이제 이런 디지털
마케팅 소프트웨어 이용하는 마케팅
AI 엔진까지 써서 하는 이런
마케팅도 이제 어 굉장히 지금은
춘추전국 시대인 거 같다. 경쟁자들이
상당히 많아서 어 어떤 기업들이
분명히 어 앞으로 툭 이제 튀어나올
텐데 매디업 매드업도 그 후보 중에
하나이겠지만 어 압도적인 지금
1등이다라고 얘기하기는 상당히 이른
시점이어서 네
>> 뭐 그런 관점에서는
>> 어 단기 투자 관점에서 접근을 좀
하고 시장의 리더가 발생하는지를 보면
아마 여기에서도 또 긴 투자 호흡에서
굉장히 좋은 수익률을 기록하는 기업을
고를 수 있을 것 같습니다.
>> 네.
한 줄만 드면이 AI 엔진으로 계속
광고하는 업체들이 하나씩 생기는 걸
보면서 어이 광고 대행하는 업체들
>> 어 그 부분들이 굉장히 업황 자체로
안 좋아질 것 같다는 생각을 굉장히
많이 했습니다. 그래서이 인건비가 전
이렇게 많이 들어가는 줄 몰랐는데
그리고 AI 그 그 엔진을 쓰면서
들어 줄어드는 시간이 거의 10배
이상 차이가 나더라고요. 그래서 그런
부분들을 봤을 때는 디지털 마케팅은
결국에 사람이 했었던 그런 디지털
마케팅 업체들은
>> 어 굉장히 어려울 수 있겠다라는
생각을 많이 했고 대체되기 굉장히
쉽겠다라는 생각을 하게 되면서
마무리를 하면 좋을 것 같습니다.
>> 동감합니다. 네.
>> 네. 오늘 일부가 좀 길었습니다.
어, 오늘 아, 7월 1일 상장
예정인 한국의 상장 예정인 매드업
공모 조 분석 보고 1부 마치도록
하겠습니다. 1부 함께 해 주신
재미탄 여러분 감사드리고요. 잠시 후
2부에서 뵙도록 하겠습니다.
감사합니다.
เฮ
안녕하세요. 행복한 투자의 여정을
체슬리 투자전과 함께 체슬리 모닝
브리프 오늘 6월 23일 파이 순서
시작하도록 하겠습니다.
자, 일부에서 공모주까지 어 커버가
되니까음 아주 좋았습니다.
원래 주니어 시절에는 공무부 분석부터
해보면 새로 올라오는 기업에 대한
자산 가치 수익 가치뿐만 아니라 상대
가치 상대 가치 보면서 피어 그룹들
상장되 있는 피어 그룹들의
밸루에이션하고 또 비교를 해 보면서
기업 공부를 하기 때문에 어 공모
기업뿐만 아니라 성장되어 있는
기업까지
봐야 되기 때문에 유니어 시절에는
공모주 분석이 이 상당히 좋은 부분
이제
공모주 분석할 때 같이 한번 관심
갖고 들어보시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
자, 이제 미국 시장은 이제 혼조새로
끝났고요. 어, 필반이 2%나
올랐는데 나스닥이 1.3%나 빠진게
보니까이
밑에 빅테크 늘려 테슬라 빼고는 다
빠져요.
>> 예. 그리고 스페이스가 16%
빠졌잖아요.
>> 예. 네. 실제로 보니까
나스닥 백에는 아직 편입돼 있지
않지만 나스닥이 상장되 있었기 때문에
나스닥 지수에는 편입이 돼 있거든요.
>> 근데 그 비
>> 아 나스닥 100은 아니지만
>> 나스닥 지수
>> 지수에는 들어가겠네요.
>> 나스닥 지수 몇 천 개 들어가
있으니까요.
>> 근데 그중에서
>> 3%나 들어가 있습니다.
>> 비중이 3%나 돼요.
>> 예. 그 16% 빠졌으니까 3 하면은
이제 거의 한 50bp 정도 한
종목이 기어를 한 거죠.
그래서 나스닥 지수가이 스페이스 X
때문에 상당히 변동성이 있을 것
같다는 생각이 들고
>> 나스닥 100백이 7월 초에 나스닥
100백에 또 7월 초에 어 편입이
되거든요. 어 그러면 이제
>> 어 그 안에서도 한 비중 자체가 어
작진 않을 텐데 어 전체 지수에
영향을 줄 것 같습니다.
미래 절래에서 스페이스섹스가 어제
전반적으로이 기술주에 대한 심리를
조금 어 부정적으로 어 영향을
주었고요. 그리고 보시면 지금 국제
10년물이 OBP가 올라서
4.55%를 기록을 했고 어 유가는
2.2%가 하락을 했어요. 근데 이게
좀 의미하는 거는 제가 볼 때는 어제
스페이스섹스가 어 상장한 적 얼마 안
돼 가지고 채권으로 자금 조달를 또
한다고 공시를 했거든요.
>> 예. 그러면서 약간 자금 시장에서
비 그 케펙스 하는 기업들 특히 이제
하이퍼스케일러들 뭐 빅테크들 뭐 다
통틀어서 약간 자금 수요 자체가
늘어나니까 막 국채 시장이든 뭐
회사치 시장이든 약간 금리를 올릴
만한 어떤 요인이 되지 않았나 이런
생각이 좀 들었습니다. 그래서 약간
그 앞으로 그 지금 케펙스를 하고
있거나 앞으로 케펙스를 할 만한 이런
기업들은 좀 일제 다 하락하는 그런
모습들이 관찰이 됐고요.
>> 특히 소프트웨어 기업들 많이 빠졌다고
얘기를 하고 있는데 어제 팔란티아도
한 7% 정도 빠졌고 YTD로
-32%입니다. 그리고 엠너빈 뭐
약록했고
오라클 뭐 로비노드 뭐 이런 기업들이
어 하락을 했고 옳은 거는 뭐 어
케픽스 수혜를 받는 어 반도체밖에
없었습니다.
그래서 아 일단 보시면은 스펙스 아
채권 발행 관련해서 기업 공시하고 어
굴버그에서 나온 뉴스를 좀 보면은
채권 발행하는 목적은 어 차익금
상환하고 일반 기업 운영이라고 적어
놨는데 시장에서는 최소한 21년 달러
이상을 어 조달할 걸로 추정을 하고
있습니다. 그런데 회사에서 지난 한
6월 19일 날 밝힌 현금하고 현금성
자산이 한 100빌년 정도 되거든요.
근데이 중에서 어 75빌리언은 IP를
통해서 어 조달한 자금일 텐데 그럼이
왜 막대한 현금 보유에도 불구하고
자금 조달을 했을까라고
보면은 기존에 어 차익금 자체가 어
조달 금리가 좀 높았는데 지금 발행을
하면은 더 나은 수준으로 어 조달할
수 있을 것이다라는 어 추정이 좀
가능하고요.
그리고 그럼 왜 100빌리ion이나
있는데이 100빌년으로 기존에
차익금을 상환하지 굳이 또 그 차원
발행을 하느냐라고 봤을 때는이
>> 백빌리어은 이미 AI 케펙스 등으로
영처가 정해져 있을 가능성이 높다고
판단이 되는데 어 실제로 그 회사가
IPO 이후에 밝힌 자금의
활용 목적에 대해서 어 75밀리언
달러를 어 AI 컴퓨팅, 인프라 확장
등이 사용할 거라고 밝히고 있습니다.
밑에 보시면은
아 이따 보시면 참 블룸 이제 컨센이
어 스페이스엑서 상장한지 얼마 안 돼
가지고 한 두 명 정도가 어 추정을
해 놨거든요. 그나마 이제 어 두 명
정도 추정해 놓은 거가 뭐 실뢰도는
좀 떨어지긴 하지만 좀 살펴보면은
스페이스의
올해하고 내년 케펙스 그 규모가 총
100빌리언 수준입니다.
예. 그래서 어
있는 어 돈은 용처가 이미 정해져
있고 어 만기가 돌아오는 어 자금들은
다시 어 차원 발행을 해서 어 만기를
연장하는 쪽으로 하지 않았을까는
생각이 [목을 가다듬음] 들고요.
어제 한 16% 정도 어 하락을
했는데 나스닥 지수를 추종하는
ETF가 2Q라는 어 ETF가 있는데
이걸 통해서 나스닥 지수에 대충요
정도 들어 그 편입이 돼 있을 수
있겠다라고 추정을 할 수 있는데 어
지금 어 시총이 어 2.18 출년
정도 되는데 스페이스 X가 한 어
나스닥 지수를 추종하는 ETF가 한
3% 정도 들어 있습니다. 나스닥
지수를 추정하는 이태프니까 나스닥
지수에다 한요 정도 정입이
돼 있을 거라는 추정이 가능하고요.이
3%가 좀 의미 있는 비중이기 때문에
나스닥 지수에도 좀 영향을 줬고 어제
같은 경우 16% 정도 하락을 했기
때문에 어 3 *하기 뭐 16하면
0.48 정도 나오니까 나스닥 지수에
-0.5% 5% 포인트 어 기여를
했을 거라고 추정이 됩니다. 그리고
이게 7월 초에 나스닥 백에 조기
편입될 거로 그 예정 예정이 돼 있기
때문에 나싹 100백에 또 편입이
되면은 나싹 백지수에도 변동성
요인으로 작용할 거로 예상이 되고
있어서
어 이래 그 빅테크가 상당한 비중을
차지하고 있는 나스닥 그리고 거기에
스페이스가 편입이 될 다스닥백 이런
그 그
지수를 추정하는 뭐 q큐큐Q큐 이런
것들은 당분간 조금 불리하지 않을까
아 이런 생각을 해해 봅니다.
연간 실적으로 보면은
실적 그 매출을 뭐 여러 세그멘트로
구분 할 수 있겠지만 그냥 통으로
보면은 왜냐면 세그먼트로 해 봐야
지금 추정하는 애널리스트가 두 명밖에
안 되기 때문에 컨센서스 실뢰들은
어차피 많이 떨어집니다. 근데 그냥
흐름 정도 보기 위해서 어 대략적으로
어떤 그림을 그릴 걸로 애널리스트들이
그나마 좀 추정하고 있는지 보면은요.
26년 어 매출은
35.8빌리언
달러 정도로 예상이 되고 있고요.
영업 이익은 한 3 -3.3빌리언
달러 정도로 예상이 되고 있습니다.
그리고 그 밑에 가서 EPS는 아
-1.1달러 1달러 정도로 예상이
되고 있고요. EPS 기준으로이
회사가
그 턴어라운드 하는 기간 시점은
2028년 정도 돼야 될 걸로 예상이
되고 있고요. 그래서 이게 중요한
거는 시총이 크고 어 미국 시장에서
어느 정도 위치를 차지하고 있기
때문에 SP 500 편입에 대한
기대를 하고 계신 분들도 계실 텐데
S&P 500은
연간 아 분기별로 4분기 이상 흑자를
어 기록을 해야 되기 때문에 EPS
기준으로 아마도이 기준으로 보면은
2028년 이후에나 어 S&P
500의 편익 가능성이 있을 걸로
예상이 됩니다.
아, 그리고 밑에 그 캐피탈 익스디처
쪽 보시면은 어, 올해가 한 45빌년
정도 되고요. 내년이 한 55빌년
정도 되고 내후년이 한 66 4빌년
정도 됩니다. 그래서 어 영업
현금흐름에서
케펙스를 뺀 어 자유헌금흐름 또는
잉여 헌금흐름 기준으로 해서
2029년에야
어 잉여헌금이 어을
기록할 걸로 예상을 하고 있고 그
이전까지는 케펙스가 40에서 한
60빌년 그리고 그 이후에 어
70빌리언 90빌년 해 가지고
엄청난 그 어 투자가 가 앞으로
들어갈 걸로 예상이 되고 있습니다.
그래서 어 투자가 이만큼 들어가기
때문에 아 탑라인에서 그리고 현금
창출 능력에 따라서 자유 현금 흐름이
현금 흐름이 플러스로 되는 시점도 좀
가변적일 수 있다는 점은 염두해 둬야
될 것 같습니다.
아, 그래서이어서 이제 그 그러면
어제 그 하이퍼스케일러들은 케펙스가
오라클 실적 발표 이후에 그 또
추정치가 변경된게 나와서 아침에 전해
드렸는데 추정치가 계속 상향되고
있는데 아 이번에는 또 뒤로 들어가서
하이퍼스틸러들 5계사에 영업 현금흐름
캠백스 인해 현금 흐름이 토탈로 지금
어떻게 되고 있는지 현재 상황에서 어
시장은 어떻게 바라보고 있는지
보시면은
2026년 27년 결론부터 얘기하면
영업 잉금흐름이
마이너스를 기록할 걸로 보고
있습니다. 얘긴 즉은 영업
현금흐음보다 케펙스가 조금 더 어
많이 잡혀 있는 상황이고요. 그리고
2028년에는
플러스로 전환한 거로 돼 있는데 요건
뭐 가봐야 되겠지만 어쨌든 시장에서는
26년 27년까지
상당한 케펙스가 일어날 걸로 보고
있고 그에 따라서 영어 잉해
현금흐름이 마이너스 될 때까지도 계속
투자가 이루어질 공격적인 투자가
이루어질 걸로 어 보고 있습니다.
그래서 이런 부분들하고 맞물려서 어
아침에 유리프로가 얘기했듯이 이런
케펙스의 수혜를 받는 곳하고
집행하는 쪽하고의 주가 차별화나
모멘텀의 처화는 당분간 계속 이어지지
않을까 싶습니다.
마이크론 실적 발표가 얼마 남지 않아
가지고 계속해서 전망치들이
되게 많이 나오고 있습니다.
비슷비슷한 내용이고 계속 그
마이크로넷에 대해서는 좋은 평가를
내고 있는데 어제 그 제프리스라는
증권사에서 메모리 아웃룩이라는
보고서를 냈는데요.
특이하게 어 본인들의
본인들만의
시각이라기보다도
그 삼성 차이나
전 어 직원인이든
탄이라고 하는 분이 있는데 이분을
초대해서 어 같이 얘기한 내용을
보고서에 실었습니다. 그래서 어 그런
부분 좀 그런데 얘기한 부분들이 어떤
부분들은 좀 일반적이기도 하고 어떤
부분들은 좀 공격적이기도 한데 특히
어 제가 계속해서 이제 팔로우하고
있는 가격 전망에 있어서 상당히
공격적인 어 전망을 내놨습니다.
일단 결론은 가격 [콧방귀] 인상은
예상을 성외할 것이고 중국은
207년까지
위협적이지 않을 것이다라고 결론을
시키면서
어 공급에 대해서는 글로벌 메모리
공급이 2026년에 7에서 8%
증가의 그치고 어네 디램 랜드는
2027년에도 쇼티지가 지속될
것이다라고 얘기를 하고 있고이
핵심에 가격 전망 쪽에서 어 얼마
전에 시티에서 에서 발간한 보고서에서
디램하고 랜드의 가격 전망을 어
말씀을 드릴 때이
부분은 저희가 보는 거보다 약간은
보수적이다라고 얘기를 하면서
시티에서 낸 가격 전망을 보면은 아
디램 쪽이 3Q에 13% 4Q에
11% 그리고 랜드 쪽이 3Q에
q큐로 17% 4Q에 6% 뭐 이런
식으로 해 가지고 올해 전체 어
디램의 Yi 가격 상승률이 어
CT에서선 200% 어 낸대 가격
상승률은 186% 이렇게 보고 있는데
여기 제프리스에서는
그보다 훨씬 더 공격적인 3Q의 가격
전망은 40에서 50% 그리고 4Q를
30에서 40% 이렇게 굉장히
공격적으로 어 전망을 내놨습니다. 어
그러면서 어제도이 부분에 약간은 어
영향을 시장에 주지 않았을까라고
생각을 하는데 어 마이크로에서 실적
발표할 때이 부분을 좀 어떻게
하느냐에 따라서 어 당일 변동성이
조금
클 것 같도 같은데 어쨌든 전망
자체는 지금까지 본 전망 중에서 가장
공격적인 전망이었던 거 같습니다.
나머지는 다 좀 일반적인 내용인데요.
HBM 같은 경우 공급부족 상태고
26년 27년 케파 증설 감한 시에
향후 12개월 HBM 가격 인상은 약
70% 수준으로 예상된다고 얘기를
했고요. 전체 메모리 연간 가격
전망이 그래서 어 시티 같은 경우는
전체가 한 200% 정도 되는데
제프리스 같은 경우는 어 전체 메모리
연간 가격 전망을 3Q 4Q에 상당히
공격적으로 잡았기 때문에 2026년에
전년 동기 대비 메모리 가격 상승이
전년 대비 6배에 달할 것이고
2027년에는 40에서 45%로
둔화될 것이고 2028년에는 에는
웨이퍼 케파 15에서 20% 증설
예상이고 가능성은 적지만 어 AI
수요가 둔화되면 가격 하락을 예상하고
있다. 그래서 어 26년 27년이
편차가 상당히 큰 상황입니다.
그리고 어 LTA 장기 공급 계약에
대해서는 클라우드 서비스
프로바이더하고만
어 체결을 하고 있는 중이고 어
40% 선급금 조건 그리고 팔에
50% 차지하고 있지만 70%까지
확대가 가능하다고 얘기를 하고
있습니다. 그리고 삼성은 어 대형 어
그 클라우드 서비스 제공 업체와 3년
LTA 계약, LTA 체결 어
가능성이 있다고 얘기를 하고
있습니다.
어 공급 업체들은 증설의 신중한
스탠스를 취하고 있는데 주요 메모리
업체들은 과거 사이클의 안 좋은
경험으로 인해서 케파를 공격적으로
늘릴 동기가 거의 없다라고 어
얘기하고 있고요. 40% 성금을
받아도 매년 수요의 지속성을 재평가할
방침이라고
하면서 어 케파 증설에 상당히 신중한
태도를 취하고 있다라고 강조하고
있고요. 아, 중국 변수에 대해서는
2026년 27년 상승 사이클에서는
기술차로 인해서 위협이 될 수 없다고
얘기하고 있고 아, 중국 케파 증설은
저가 세그멘트에만 영향이 있고 다만
랜드는 장기적으로 위협적이고
CXMT의 디램 기술은 1.5에서
2세대 뒤쳐져 있고 EUV 없이는
DDR6 HBM 3e가 불가능하다라고
어 언급을 했습니다. 그리고 HB는
2027년 증가하겠지만 여전히 두
세대 주쳐지며 격차는 확대될 것으로
예상하고 있다고 언급을 했습니다.
그래서 어 제가 주목해서 본 거는이
가격 전망에서 굉장히 공격적이다라는
생각을 좀 했고요. 어 과연이
부분에서 어 마이크론 테크놀러지 실적
발표 과정에서 얼마나이 부분을 좀
확인시켜 줄까가 좀 관건일 것
같습니다. 이상입니다.
알겠습니다.
어, 되게 좀 중요하고 저도지 신경
써 있던 부분이 중국 업체들의
위협이었어 일단 27년까지는
위협적이지 않고 실제로 그럴 거예요.
아마 보죠.
그리고 제일 1 나오지만 일단 랜드는
장기적으로 위협적이고
그리고 CXN 디램 기술이 이게
1.5세대 2세대 뒤차졌다라는게
1.5년 2년 얘기는 아니죠. 이게
>> 아 그 나노 단위로 보신 거
같습니다. 지금은 지금
>> 원 C 시 시대거든요. 10 10나노
초반 때 10난호 11나노 근데
CXMT는 16나도 온도 세대기
때문에 한 2세대 정도 됩니다. 세대
정도
>> 그러면
그리고
나노 C까지 올라오면 근데 EUB는
또 안 되는 거 아닌가요? 아,
DUB로 해도 되긴 하는데 이제 더블
패턴인 트리플 패턴 하면서 2중
3중을 해야 돼서 원가가 굉장히 많이
들면
>> 창신 메모리에서는 HBM 3e를
내년에 출시한되나요?
>> 지금이 HBM 3 일단은 올해까지
출시하려고 하고 있고요. 올해까지는
>> 예. 3 2는 아직은 모르겠어요.
>> 아 3는 올해 출시한다. 이렇게 돼
있고.
>> 알겠습니다.
그리고 여기 장기 공급 계약기도 되게
자세하게 잘 적혀 있네요. 보니까.
>> 예.
3년 장격 공급계약 그것도 40번째
선거금 받고 지금 이런 상황이라고 돼
있습니다.
자,이 하이퍼스러들의
프리캐시플로우가
올해 내년까지는 마이너스
>> 예, 그렇습니다. 지금 현재 어,
블룸버그 추정으로는 이렇게 되는데 제
생각은 더 마이너스로 갈 수도 있을
것 같습니다.
>> 어, 그러게.
>> 예.
그 지금
작년까지의
M7에 그 거처 없는 상승 때문에
>> 예
>> 23년 24년 미국 예외주의했을 때
그 시장을 이끌었던게 다이
M7이었는데
>> 그렇습니다. 예.
>> 그걸 뒤늦게 투자하신 분들은 왜
이렇게 수익이 안 되지?
>> 예. 그러고 계실 건데 실제
주는 환원을 할 수 있는 재원이 될
수 있는 프리캐시플로가 이렇게
마이너스로 24년부터 25년 들어갈
때 줄여들기 시작해서 26년
27년에는
마이너스를 기록하고 있고 28년
돼서야 이제 큰폭으로 다시 증가한다고
보니까 이것만 보면 어 내년 한
중순에서 내년 말에 다시 좀 사야
되겠다 이런 생각이 예. 그래서
지금이 사이클의 변곡점이 어디가를 좀
>> 잘 짚는 것이 어 이번 그여
투자의 핵심인 거 같습니다. 내가 볼
때는이 그 인프라사이클이 끝나게 되면
분명히 위너가 나타날 것이고
>> 그 위너가 거의 다 가져갈 것인데 그
위너를 그때는 좀 의미 있게 잡아
가지고 끌고는
>> 투자가 어 의미하지 않을까 싶습니다.
>> 근데 보통 그 위너가
>> 예
>> 좀 구조 조정 시기가 오고 위너가
나오지 않아요. 그래서
>> 지금 막 질러되고 있는이
>> 하이프 스킬러 중에서도 특히나음
AI 쪽은 오픈 AI이냐 앤스로틱이냐
재미나이냐예
>> 그 세 개가 다 공존
수도 있고 3등은 좀 달라갈 수도
있고 이게 너무 많이 빨리 막 바뀌어
가지고
>> 뭐 좀 가음하기가 어려운 거
같습니다.
데 뭐 누가 됐든간에
어
알 수는 참 없고요. 어쨌든 어 돈을
많이 공격적으로 쓰는 구간이기 때문에
수혜를 받는 쪽에 일단은 조금 더 좀
집중해야 되지 않을까 싶습니다.
>> [목을 가다듬음]
>> 일단 저 제일 앞단에서는 생존을
위해서 뭐 돈 빌려서도 지금 계속
진러되고 있고
>> 예.
>> 최부 사장님 보시기에는이
프리 캐시플러가 좀 더 마이너스 폭이
깊을 수도 있다.
>> 왜냐면 더 질러돼야 되기 때문에
그죠.
>> 그렇게 또 생각하시는 거. 마치 그
죄소의 딜레마라는
>> 음
>> 그 이론 있잖아요.
>> 거기에서 이제
>> 어 둘 다 협의에서 잘하면 되는데
남이 어떻게 할지 모르니까 일단 일단
질러보고
>> 어 생각하자. 어
>> 그런 양상이냥 나타나고 있지 않나
싶습니다.
>> 그러겠지긴
했는데 아직까지는 공모가보다는
위연해요. 공모가가 130인데
154.6이니까 6이니까
>> 예
>> 그렇지만 어 이게 나스닥 조기 편입이
예정되 있기 때문에 나스닥백 편입
전에는 그래도 조금 반등이 있을 거
같은데 그 나스닥 편입에 대한 이벤트
드리번으로 투자했던 분들이
[목을 가다듬음] 약간 당황스러울 거
같아.
>> 예.
근데 이번에 편입을 하는데도 주가가
못 올라오면 주가가 올라오든 못
올라오든 약간 그래도 비중을
[콧방귀] 좀 줄여놨다가 좀 봐야
되지 않나 그런 생각도 들긴 합니다.
지금 PSR이 100배잖아요.
뭐 그렇고 저 그냥 저는 개인적으로
아
이벤트 드리분도 쉽지 않다 이렇게
생각을 하는게 어 지난번에 잠깐
말씀드렸듯이 날싹백이 편입이 되면 한
1% 정도 비중으로 들어갈 거거든요.
1% 정도 비중으로 들어갔는데
>> 그 1%가 그렇게 큰 임팩트가 있는
건 아니거든요. 그래서 나스닥을
추종하는 ETF들이 기계적으로 산다고
하더라도 제가 볼 때는이
펀더멘탈한
요인들을 감안을 해 볼 때
그냥 개인적으로 한 그다지 큰 매력은
없어 보이거든요.
>> 네.
>> 예.
저는 이제 좀 중장기로 생각을 하는
사람이니까 이제
>> 어 이벤트들이 드리분으로
인한 어 트레이딩 기획을
쉽게 줄까 이런 생각을 조금 하고
있습니다.
그리고 어제 워신박 신문에서 그
스페이스엑스 관련된 기사가 하나
있었는데
>> 예. 예. 예.이
>> 미국의 교수 부부가 쓴 책이 있는데
그 책에 대한 소개였는데
>> 예.
어, 엘리머스가 2050년에
화성에다가 100만 명,
>> 100만 명 얘기했거든요.
2050년에
20 한 4년 뒤에 24년 뒤에
화성에 100만 명이나 가는 도시가
세워질 수 있나 그런 생각인데 근데
그 교수 부부의 얘기는
>> 예
>> 어 지구가 핵전쟁으로 멸망하고 나서의
지구 방경이
>> 예
>> 화성보다는 나을 거다. 어,
반대로 [콧방귀] 얘기하면 그렇게
화성이 좀 어, 정박 여약하다
얘네요. 네.
>> 그리고 그 동물 시험이나 이런 걸
갖다가 해 보면 예.이
>> 우리는 지구상에서이 지구의 중력에 그
DNA가 맞춰져 있잖아요.
>> 예.
>> 그래서 우주로 가거나 그랬을 때이
중력도 달라지고
>> 음.
그때 출산이 제대로 될지 뭐 그런
것부터
>> 여러 가지
>> 어 - 60도
다가 이런저런 얘기를 써 놨는데
>> 그 한마디로
핵전쟁 이후에 멸망한 지구보다
화상이 더 열악하
>> 음
>> 그런 얘기를 딱 보면서 그거 하나로도
어 그러면 화석에 [콧방귀] 100만
명 이거는 좀 아닐 수도 있겠구나
그때까지 어느 정도 기술 발달이
있을지 모르겠지만
좀 되겠습니다.
자, 미국은 여기까지 하고 예, 국내
시장으로 넘어가 보도록 하겠습니다.
네, 전일 시장 말씀드리겠습니다.
코스피가 [목을 가다듬음] 0.7%
7% 가량 상승으로 마감을 했었고요.
코스닥이 보합 정도의 상승
마감했습니다.
수급적으로 보면 개인 투자자 2조대
매수세 유입됐었고요. 반면에 외국인이
차익 실현을 좀 많이 했었는데 2조
5천억 가량물 매도가 있었습니다.
반면 기관에서는 3,억가량 제가
유입되기도 했었고요.
투자자를 매매 동향 보면 어제 외국인
투자자는 LG 이노텍
HD 현대중 미래 S세 두산
SK텔레콤 IPS 등을 매수를
했었고요. 매도에는 SK닉스 SK
스퀘어 삼성전자 삼성전기
현대차 LG 전자 등을 매도했습니다.
기관 매수에는 SKX 그리고 삼성전기
SK 스퀘어 LG 전자 등을 매수를
했었고요.
반면 매도 쪽에는 삼성전자, 현대차,
현대 중업, 현대 모비스 등을
매도했습니다.
52주 신고가 종목 총 19 종목이
나왔는데
코스피에서 SK닉스, SK 스케어
지주를 매수를 했었고요. 그 외에는
뭐 삼성전기 우선주 등을
매수했습니다.
포스닥에서선 PSK 그리고 제주
반도체 하나마이크론
테스 VM 기가비스 등이 신고가에
이름을 올리면서 코스닥에서는 반도체
소부장 종목들이 상당히 좀 강한
모습이 나타났습니다.
아니 외국인이 지금 코덱스 SK
하이닉스 두 배를 이렇게 많이
쐈어요.
>> 네. 139.
>> 그리고 본주는
이만큼 팔고
>> 네.
>> 어,
>> 그거는 좀 이상하다. 그죠? 둘 다
사든지.
>> 왕박사는 왜 그렇다 생각이?
모르겠습니다. 왜 레버지 사는지
>> 이거 외부 개인인지
기관인지 구분하지 못합니다.
>> 그러게.
검은머리 외국인이인지 않을까요?
>> 음. 저도 그렇게 생각하는데
52 신고가 종목은 15개 아
19개. 어
주요 종목들 동장 한번 보겠습니다.
네. 반도체 벡터 먼저 살펴보면
삼성전자가 약법권 정도로 마감하면서
하이닉스와의 주가 차별화가 계속해서
나타나고 있는 모습이고요. 하이닉스는
5.6% 상승하면서 홀로 좀 강한
모습이 한 2주간 계속 지속이 되는
거 같아요.이 이 괴리가 계속
벌어지고 있는 상황이고 어제 우선주를
제외하고는 하이닉스가 삼성자의 시가
총액을 따라잡으면서
어 시총 1위로 올라서 상황이 지금
우선주 포함하면 아직까지는 그래도
전자가 시총 1이라고 볼 수가
있겠고요. 소부장 종목들도 상당히
강했는데 한미 반도체 2% 올랐고 뭐
HPSP 이오테크 원니가이패스 IS
심텍 두산테스나 지금 대체로
뭐 적게는 2% 많게는 7 8%씩
상승하면서 소부장에서도
[목을 가다듬음]
온기가 좀 확산되는 모습이 전에는
나타났던 거 같고요. IT 섹터에선
삼성 전기가 좀 쉬어가는 흐름이
나왔습니다. 1.8% 8%
하락을 했었고요.
LG 전자가 최근에 주가 계속
빠졌었는데 전장에서 그래도 반등을
일부 좀 하긴 했습니다. 플랫폼
섹터는 어 대체로 계속해서 부신한
흐름 이어나가고 있고 네이버가 다시
주가가 많이 내려오면서 포워드피
16배까지 빠진 상황입니다. DK
지수 1.5%가량 5%가량 상승
마감했는데
반도체 쪽이 역시나 좋았습니다. 도쿄
일렉트론 3%대 올랐고요. 무라타
4%
디스코 이비된 어드반테스트 등 대체로
다 강세로 방했습니다. 그래서 어제는
무라타와이 [목을 가다듬음]
되는 강세를 보였는데 전기는
상대적으로 약한 모습이
나타났었거든요. 이렇게 이비과
무라타가 강하게 유지가 되는 전기도
결국 따라가는 모습이 나타나더라고.
그래서 추가흐름을 좀 봐야겠고
자동차 섹터 어제 안 좋았습니다.
현대, 기아, 뭐 모비스, 오토에버
다 약세에 마감했고요. 확실히 그
FOMC에서 올해 금리 인상 확률이
좀 올라가고 좀 매파적으로 나오다
보니까 코스닥에 있는 로봇도 그렇고
포스페인은 로봇으로 엮겨 있는
성장주들도 주가가 힘을 좀 잃는
모습이 나타나는 거 같습니다. 소비제
섹터는 뭐 대형 화장품 대체로 부진한
흐름이었고요. 피오 미용 기기는 좀
혼조세였는데
클레나 파마, AP등들은 약세였지만
슈젤과
[콧방귀] 원택은 또 상승세로
마감하게 됐습니다. 음식료 섹터는
농심 사명 식품 약세로 마감을
했었고요.
어 백화점 체인 좋았습니다. 신세계나
현대 백화점 상승세가 마감 있습니다.
어 조선 철강및 기타 섹터 봐 주시면
어제 조선주 특별한 이슈 없이 다
크게 하락했습니다. 중이나 하나
오션, 하나 엔진 액세로 마감을
했고요. 그래서 다 지금 많이
내려와서
현중이 20배, 하나 오션 20배,
하나 엔진 20배 미만해서 거래가 된
상황 그리고 아래 철강이나 화학도
대체로 약세로 마감을 했고요.
방산주 봐 주시면 하나 여로가 보합
정도. 넥스년대 로템이 약세였습니다.
어제 장 시작했을 때만 해도
방산주름은 괜찮았었는데 바로 매물
쏟아지면서 좀 내려오는 모습으로
마감을 했던 기억이 있고요. 유럽의
라인 메탈의 주가가 상당히
약하더라고요. 고점 대비
2000유로가 아마 고점이었는데 지금
한 100유로까지 내려와 있습니다.
4월 거의 뭐
>> 단순 가까이 빠졌네요.네
>> 맞습니다. 어 주가가 상당히 많이
내려와 있는 상황으로 볼 수가 있어서
뭐 글로벌하게 휴전 쪽으로 좀
이야기가 나오기 시작할 때부터 좀
많이 빠지긴 했거든요.
최근에 라인 메탈만의 개별적인 이슈는
3계분기 연속 어닝을 미스하긴
했습니다. 그래서 어 상대적으로
약하고 방산주들 국내 방산주들도 많이
약한 상황인데
[목을 가다듬음]
뭐 어쨌든 이럴 때가 항상
기회였다라는 생각이 들기는 합니다.
그리고 바이오섹터는 대체로
구진했고요. 뭐 코스피 바이오나
코스닥 바이오
약세를 시현을 했고 아래 금융이나
증권주들도 부진했습니다. 엔터 쪽은
하이브가 어제 뭐 특별한 이슈 없이
4.7% 크게 하락하는 모습 나왔고
나머지도 비슷했습니다.
변악기 쪽도 지난 금요일에 좀 좋았던
걸로 기억이 나는데 어제에서 또 차익
실은 나왔습니다.
>> 네.
자, 저희 자료를 보시면 어, 많이
빠지면 많이 빠질수록지 파란색으로
표시가 되고 많이 오를수록지
빨간색, 붉은색으로 표시가 되는데
지금 보면 왼쪽 반도체 소부장하고
IT 상단에 있는 삼성전기, 전자
이노택 뭐요 정도. 그다음에 밑에
일본도 반독체 장비 회사인 도쿄
일렉트론하고 그다음에
어 삼성전기랑 피어에 있는
무라타라든지이 기고는
별 재미가 없고요. 그리고 오른쪽에
소비제 쪽으로 쭉 가도 신세계
백화점하고 현대 백화점 정도 붉은색
나오고 있고 자동차도 최근에
무너지고 있고 그죠?
네. 조선 철강화요 무거운 적이버
엔트까지
금융도 뭐 최근에 좀 많이 빠지고
키움 정권 뭐 26% 빠졌고
이런 식으로
보면 시장이
지수가 우리가 반도체 비중에 50%가
넘다 보니까 지수가 오르는 것처럼
보이지만 실제적으로 보면은 약간
약세장에 진입했다는 느낌에서는 계속
받아
약세량을 지입했고 그죠?
>> 네.
그래서 뭐 9천 넘어서 대게 과일처럼
모지했지만
사실 시장 자체는 약사장으로
진입됐다. 근데이 약세장이
어 대세 하락으로 전환한게 아니라 한
3 이번 하반기 항상 중간 선거
전까지 7 8 9 10 어 요게
약세장이고이
약세장이라는 말은 주가가 지금 싸지고
있잖아요.
싸지고 있기 때문에 또 다른 기회가이
약세장 속에서 만들어지고 있는
거거든요.
굉장히 지금 양극화가 심화되고 있다.
>> 그렇죠.
>> 미국이나 한국이나 공통적인 상황인 거
같습니다.
>> 예. 공통적인 그러니까
>> 그런 시장의 모습이 더 경배되고
있고요.
자, 리포트 가져오신 거 한번
보겠습니다. 소득이 생산을 앞을 때
한국 증시 재평가의 시간. 어, 하나
김도원 자료님.
>> [목을 가다듬음]
>> 어 흑주식 시장 전략은 금리 부담을
이유로 비중을 줄이는 것이 아니라
소득이 생산 앞서는 산업을 더 사는
것이다라는 이야기를 했는데요. 실질
GDI가 GDP를 크게 추월한
국면에서는 메모리 반도체를 비롯한
AI 병목 산업을 중심에 두고 환율
안정시 수출주 비중을 추가 확대하는
전략이 좀 유효하다라고 합니다. 어,
금융주와 고배당주는 금리 상승의
보완축으로 활용이 가능하다라고 하고
매수주는 훈순위로 보고 있다라고
하는데요. 이번 장세의 본질은 경기
침체가 아니라 한국 기업이의
재평가라고 볼 수가 있겠다라고
합니다.
뭐 글로벌 통화 정책의 방향도
변화되고 있다라고 하는데 연주는 기준
금리를 동결하긴 했는데요. 물가
안정을 우선하고 있고 ECB와
BOJ는 어 정상화 기조를 이어가고
있다라고 합니다. 그래서 22이
비워져 있는 금리를 최근에 인상을
했었고 한국은행 역시 금리 인상
글로벌 통화 정책 아 금리 인상
가능성이 좀 남아 있다라고 하고 다만
이번 금리 압력은 침체가 아닌 성장
물가 환율 소득계선이 동시에 만든
정상화 과정에 가깝다라고 볼 수가
있겠고요. 한국의 차별점은 소득
개선에 있다라고 볼 수가 있겠는데
1분기 실질 GDP는 전년 동기 대비
3.8%
성장한 반면에 실질 GDI는
13.2% 2% 증가하면서 생산보다
소득이 훨씬 빠르게 개성이 됐다라고
합니다. 그리고이는 한국 경제가
단순히 더 많이 생산하는 단계를
넘어서 더 비싸게 판매할 수 있는
구간에 진입했음을 의미한다라고
하고요. 핵심은 교육 조건 개선이라고
볼 수가 있겠는데 반도체 가격 상승
HBM 병무 메모리 가격 결정의
회복이 동시에 나타나면서 같은 물량을
판 매도 높은 이익을 창출하는 구조가
형성이 되고 있다. 과거 반도체
사이클이 물량 중심이었다면 이번
사이클은 가격 중심이라는 점이 가장
큰 차이라고 하고요. 어 GDI가
GDP를 앞서는 국면은 생산보다
소득이 빠르게 증가하는 시기로 뭐
기업의 EPS나 현금을 투자 요력이
동시에 개선이 될 수가 있겠다라고
합니다. 그래서 과거 GDY와 GDP
역전 사례를 살펴보면 미국과 한국은
해석이 좀 다를 수가 있겠는데요.
미국은 GDI가 GDP보다 먼저
둔화될 경우 기업 이익이나 임금 신용
둔화의 경고 신호로 작용을 해왔다.
반면 한국은 교육 조건과 구매력
변화의 결과로 수출 가격이 수익
가격보다 빠르게 올 경우 GDI가
GDP를 상의했다라고 하고요. 따라서
현재 한국의 상황은 미국 침체
신호보다 수출기업 이익 재평가 신호에
좀 가깝다라고 하고 미국은 26년
1분기 실제 GDP 1.6 실질
GDI 0.9%로 9%로 소득의
생산을 따라가지 못하고 있다라고
합니다. 반면에 한국은 실제 GDP
3.8, 실.
소득기 생산을 크게 앞섰다라고
합니다. 1988년 이후 최대이
괴리라고 하더라고요. GDI가 이렇게
많이 올라갔게.
>> 음.
[목을 가다듬음]
그래서 2는 반도체 수출 단가 상승과
교육 조건 개선의 결과로 우리가
해석을 할 수가 있겠는데 전력적
함의네 가지 정도로 꼽았습니다. 첫째
주도주는 여전히 반도체라고 볼 수가
있겠고요. 이번 GDI 계선의
출발점은 소비가 아닌 수출단과 기업
마진으로가 볼 수가 있겠고 HBM
메모리 장비 그리고 소재 AI
인프라가 핵심수의 업종으로 볼 수가
있겠다. 그 둘째는 환율 한정이
재평가의 방화세라고 볼 수가
있겠는데요. 원화 약세는 수출기압의
이익 레버리지를 높이는 요인이고 원화
변동성이 안정되면 시장은 다시
EPS에 집중하게 된다. 과거
3조환기 역시 소득 개선과 원화
약세가 동시에 나타나면서 한국증시에서
강세를 이끌어졌다.
세 번째는 금융주와 고배당주는
보안축으로 활용이 가능하다라고
하고요. 금리 인상의 배경이 명목
성장과 소득 개선이라면 예대맞진
확대가 나타날 수가 있겠고 배당이나
자본 적책 등이 부각될 수가 있다.
넷째 내 수준은 좀 후순이라고
본다라고 하는데요. 현재 소득 증가는
소비보다 기업 이익과 투자력 개선으로
먼저 나타나고 있어서 소비제 유통주는
실질 임금 및 소비 심리 회복하기
이후 접근하는 것이 접절하다라는
이야기를 했는데 이미 근데 소비제에서
튀오른 종목들은 좀 있기 때문에 뭐이
의견은 뭐 전체적인 소비제 전반을
얘기하는 거 같습니다. 어추 리스크는
반도체 가격 상승 두나 원자가격 상승
그리고 과도한 금리 인상 등을 꼽을
수가 있겠고요. 다만 중요한 것은
금리의 방향이 아니라 금리가 오르는
이유로 볼 수가 있겠는데 성장과 소득
개선에 기반한 금리 상승 국면에서는이
개선주 중심의 접근이 좀 더 유효하고
실제 GDI가 GDP를 앞선 현재는
한국 증시 재평가 국면으로 판단을 할
수가 있겠다라는 의견을 제시했습니다.
그래서 지금 금리가 오르는 이유
그리고 인플레이션이 있는 이유가
결국에는
성장과 소득 개선에 기반을 하고 있기
때문에 경기 침체 쪽보다는 성장
쪽으로의 나타나는 금리 상승으로
해석을 할 수가 있다. 그런 이야기로
정리를 할 수 있을 것 같습니다.
>> 특이한 분석이네요.
>> 그러니까
>> 예.
했음
>> GDP 이거 얘기할 때
영토 기준이잖아요.
>> 음. [목을 가다듬음] 국가
뭐 생산하든 내국인이든 외국인이든이
>> 영토 안에서 생산된 산출물을 화폐
가치로 측정을 한 거잖아요.
>> 근데 미국 사례를 보면 이제 우리는
그 기업에 투자하니까 어 미국
기업들의
40 SMP 500에 기업들의
40%가 해외 매출이거든요. 해외
매출은 GDP에는 포함은 안 되고
기업 실적에는 포함되고 그죠? 그래서
어 저는 이제 GDP로 특히 국내는
잘 모르겠어요.
미국은 이제 GDP로 해 가지고
이사 결정을 하는 거는 조금 유하지
않다고 보는 편입니다.
그리고 또 하나가 예,
>> 여기 실질 GDI가
>> 총소득이
국내 총소득이 GDP를 크게
추원했다고 막 이러는데이
아마 다 체감이 우리가 그렇게 소득이
크게 늘었나
그런 느낌이 좀 봤잖아. 그지?
소백이 크게
예. 그 박스리한테 말씀드리긴
했었는데
>> 소득이 생각보다 엄청 많이
들었더라고요.
>> Y와Y로 15% 이상씩 습니다.
>> 어,
>> 여기 소득에 주식도 수익
>> 그러게요. 궁금하로
>> 그지? 임금 기준이잖아. 거의가.
>> 삼성전자 하이닉스 다니시는 분들의이
보너스가 영향을 많이 주나 보네.
>> 그런 거.
>> 자본 이득은 안 들어가고요. 생산
활동으로 창출된 소득만 들어간다고.
이런 거 보면 어떻게 보면 GDI도
이렇게 크게 증가를 했는데 방금 자본
소득이나 뭐 집값 상승이나 이런 실제
부의 효과에 직접적인 영향을 주는 거
>> 또 따로 있는 거잖아요.
>> 그렇죠. 그런 거 보면 지금 소비제가
지금 완전히 주가가 죽쓰고 있는 거
>> 어 여기에 어떻게 보면 기회가 있을
수가 있다. 그죠? 네. 그럴 수
있을 것 같습니다.
요즘 저녁에 보면 사람들 많졌어.
과거 방거 그렇지 않아요?
뭐 저도 백화전 같은데 잘 안
다니는데 주식으로 좀 벌거나 이제
월급 들어오면은 좀 멋수도
한번 먹어보고지
>> 한 3, 4년 전에 생각도 못 한
것들을 먹고 있기 때문에 저도 저도
수비가 많이
>> 이전 대비로 늘어난 거 같습니다.
우리 최부 사장님도 뭐 백화점이나
이런 쇼핑 이런 거랑 전혀 상관이
없다 보니까
>> 상관없습니다. 근데 그런 분들이
있더라고요. 그
>> 그런 분들 좀 뿌듯한데
>> 어 주식으로 돈 벌어서 그 애 학비
내고
>> 어 뭐
>> 국가품 사는데 도움이 됐다 이런
말들을 때 좀 뿌듯합니다.
>> 그렇죠. 우리 여기 채팅망에 솔트님도
배행 갔다 오시고예.
>> 워신방 댓글 보면 의외로 이번에
중심으로 보셔 가지고
>> 어 뭐 어디 놀러 갔다 오셨다 뭐
이런 거 꽤 많아. 그렇습니다.
>> 플스 진짜
>> 플렉스 하시는 분들
>> 여기 보기 님이 저도 이제 두부 가격
안 보고 사고 있다고 봅니다.
[웃음]
그렇습니다.
어 리포터의 큰 내용은 그래도 말은
되는 얘기다. 그렇죠?
>> 자 그리고 그다음 리포트가 성장하는
단거리 반공 체계 시장 대신 최종원
연구원 자료 가지고 오셨네.
저는 좀 방산 지금 되게 좋게 보고
있어 가지고 자꾸 가져오게 되는데요.
>> 성장하는 단거리 방책의 시장이라고
하는데 여전히 유요한 투자 포인트가
남아 있다라고 하고 저렴해진
밸류에이션 이야기를 했습니다. 1분기
실적 발표 이후 지금 수주 공백기가
계속 나오고 있고 뭐 작년 재작년만
해도 분기마다 수주 막 뉴스 나오고
텔레 돌면서 주가가 엄청
펌핑됐었잖아요.
지금 수주 이야기들이 좀 많이
잠잠해졌는데
어 국내 방사업체들의 주가 부신이
지속이 되고 있고 미국 전쟁 종전에
따라 지연되었던 중동내 사업 가속화가
앞으로는 그래도 좀 나올 수 있지
않을까라는 이야기를 했습니다. 현재
주가는 방의 선업의 구조속 성장을
바라보는 투창자들에게 매력적인 별료
정도로 보여지고요. 당사 방의산업
커버리지사에 대한 매수 의견까지
유지를 했습니다. 자, 미국 권역
지속 지원 체계라고 해서 RSF라고
하는데 인도 태평양 지역 내에서 좀
기회가 있지 않나라는 이야기를
했는데요.
미국의 방의산업 공격마 병목으로 인해
미국 단독으로는 안보 수요 충족이
현재 어렵다라고 하고 미국 24년
한국 등 동맹국가 RSF 그리고
안태산업 회복력 파트너십을 체결을
하면서 인도태평 지역을 핵심 매모로
허브로 격상시켰다라고 하고요.이는
이는 국내 방해산업의 기회로 상향후에
작용할 수도 있다라고 전망했습니다.
어 저가대량 무기체와 제조업 영량이
중심이 된 현대 구조에서 한국은
미국이 필요로 하는 제조업 기반을
제공할 수 있는 어 최적의 아시아
파트너 국가로 볼 수가 있겠고요.
하나 에어로는 한국 호주 인도
사업장을 통해 K9이나 천무 레드백
등을 생산하고 있고 자회사들과 함께
항공 우주 그리고 지상 등 다
영역에서 미국의 안보분단 기조에 따른
전력 공백을 보완할 수 있다라고
합니다. 그리고 뭐 무엇보다 제일
중요한게 그 유럽인데요. 프랑스
중심의 유럽 자각론이 강화되고
있음에도 불구하고 프랑스나 독일이
추진하던 6세대 전투기 공동개발
프로그램이 정격 중단되면서 이유
내에서도 국가 경제적 이익이 정치적
논리보다 우선된다는 점이 확인이 되고
있다라고 합니다. 이에 따라 유럽
방위 산업 통합이 지연될 가능성이
높아진 상황이고이는 한국 방위 산업의
기회로 장용할 수가 있겠다. 직출
확대뿐만 아니라 동유럽 기반 현지화
전략이나 어 전략 그리고 LIG
DNA 라인 메탈 이번에 합작법인
설립했다라고 했고요. 하나
에로스페이스 그리고 탈레스 파트너십과
같은 협력을 통한 수출 증가가
기대된다라고 합니다.이 하나에로와
탈레스 파트너십은 주말 간에도 나왔던
이슈였습니다.
중동쪽은 미국의 인도한 집중 전략
중동 국가들의 전략적 자율 확대
움직임에 따라 어 중동 국가들의 방위
산업 자립파 수요가 증가할 것이다.
그리고 단거리 방공책에 이야기도
했는데요. 이게 SHAD 이게 숏 어
레인지 에어로디펜스라고 해서 짧은
거리 이제 쏘는 방공책의 미살이라고
할 수가 있겠는데 레이저 기반 대공
무기체계 기술적 관계로 인해 단기간
내 드론 위협에 대응할 수 있는 전망
확산탄 금접 신간 폭발탄 기반 대공포
시장 전망이 성장이 어 전망이
된다라고 하는데 국내에서는 하나여로의
H숏 라드 그리고 LIS DNA
102 2 LSAM 등이 있고요.
하나씩 있을 때 청광 등에 주목할
필요가 있다라고 합니다.
유럽 쪽 지금 미국에서 계속 어
압박을 하고 있고 유럽 내에서도
GDP 대비 4%까지 방위비 지출을
늘리려고 하고 있잖아요.
>> 음. 그에 따라서 이제 대공 방어
미사일 책에도 도입이 확 돼야 되는데
거기서
LI [목을 가다듬음] DNA 하나
에어로스페이스 하나 시스템이 수혜를
받을 수 있다. 이야기로 해석을 할
수가 있습니다. 왜냐면 그 청투도
그렇지만 LSM도 그렇고 세 개사가
다 들어가거든요. 세계사의 역량이
그런 부분을 투자 포인트로 꼽는 거
같습니다.
[목을 가다듬음] 자, 여전히 어
투자 포인트가 훼손되지는 않고 그죠.
유연한 투자 포인트인데 가격은 이제
떨어지고 있으니까 점점 더 저렴하게
>> 주식을 살 수 있다.
>> 그런 내용이었습니다.
자, 어제는 우리나라 시장에 큰
이변이 있었는데 하이닉스가 시가
총력이 1등으로 올랐었다. 그죠?
오늘도 아마 그 분위기가 이어질 것
같은데.
>> 네. 신기하게도 지금 마이너스가 나고
있는데요. 어제 야간 선물이 1.9%
정도 올라간 거 같은데 지금 지수가
마이너스가 좀 나고 있습니다.
>> 어 시장은 어떻게 시작했어요?네
>> 어 - 0.34%로 하락해서
출발했고요. 어 지금 이제 플러스가
막 어 나기 시작을 했고요.
0.08% 플러스가 나고 있고 전자
이닉스가 마이너스입니다. 어 코스닥은
어떻게 되죠?네 네. 코스닥은 -1%
하락해서 출발했고요. 현재 +
0.21% 21% 어 상승하고
있습니다.
[목을 가다듬음] 자 우선주를 더하면
뭐 전자가 시총이 더 크다 뭐
이러기는 하지만 우선주 더하면 뭐
PER도 약간 더 높게 계산될 수도
있고 이번에 하이닉스가 ADR
발행하잖아요.
>> 그거는 신주 발행해서 미국에다가
상장시키는 거죠. 예. 그렇게 하고
있습니다. 예. 그래서 나중에 그
논란도 있을 것 같아. 하이닉스는
미국 ADR라고 합쳐서 시총 봐야
된다. 이렇게
>> 삼성전자는 우선주 합쳐서 봐야 된다면
[웃음] 그잖아.
>> 어차피 발행된 수집이니까
>> ADR라고 [콧방귀]
합쳐서 보면 하이닉스의 시총 1위가
조금 더 이어질 것 같기도 한데
>> 그죠? 한 달, 두 달 정도는 더
이어질 수도 있을 것 같고 그게
굳어질 수도 있고
>> 예.
>> ADR이
어느 경 어느 정도 규모로 지금 신주
반행 하나 모르겠네요.
>> 전체 10.5% 얘기하더라고요.
2.5%요.
>> 어, 2.5%.
>> 예. 전체 2.5%고
나스닥이 일단 상장이 되고 그리고
필반 지수에 들어갈 수도 있는데
>> 그 필반 지수는 유동 시총
기준이거든요. 그래서
>> 보시면은 TSMC나 ASMR이나 뭐
시총 크잖아요. 근데 뒤에가
있거든요. 유동 시종 기준으로 하기
때문에. 그래서 하이닉스가 어 필반
지수에 들어가는 건 맞는데 임팩트는
조금 그 유동 시청 기준이기 때문에
뒤로 밀릴 가능성이 있는데 제가 볼
땐 그래도 어 미국에 상장되는
것만으로도 멀티플이 어 올라가는
>> 그 효과는 분명히 있을 것 같습니다.
그래서 어 마이크론 지금 열배 받고
있고 하이닉스 뭐 일곱 배 받고
있는데
여덟 배 아홉 기름배 뭐요 정도까지
가면 좋지 않을까라는 바람은
있습니다.
>> 예 2.5% 정도 발린다단 말이죠.
>> 예 저는 그렇게 알고 있어요.
>> 그러면 2,000조에 2.5조
정도네. 40조 정도 45조 45조
정도 신주 유상진자 발행해서
>> 그걸로 이제 레이 성장을 시키고
그리고 그
발행한 주식주만큼 바로 자사주를
매입해서 수박했습니다.
아 그 발행한 주식수만큼은
자사주를 사서 소각하니까 총 주식수가
변동이 없도록
>> 원래 기존에는 자사주를 있는 걸로
매일 상장을 하려고 했는데 그게 사법
계정 때문에 자수를 이용 못 하게끔
있어서
>> 바라습니다.
그리고 제가 그 뉴욕에 갔을 때
시타데 아 시타데리아네 스티베리라는
조금 조그만 증권사에 갔는데 거기
리서스 센터장 트레이딩룸을 구경시켜
주더라고요. 그래서
>> 거기 뭐 몇십 명이 어
>> 그 트레이딩을 하고 있는데
>> 시타드
>> 아 시타드 아니고 스티펠 스티
스티펠이라는 조건사인데 상장이 돼
있습니다. 한 10 12빌리언
달러 정도 시총을 가지고 있는 어
증권사인데 거기가 한투가 하고 같이
뉴욕에서 협업을 하는 증권사래요.
그래서 어 왠지 않게 그 트레이딩룸을
가서 그 사람들하고 좀 얘기를 해
봤는데 주식 채권 금리 뭐 크마더티
다 한대요. 그래서 저희가 한국에
대한 익스포가 있냐 물어봤는데 없다고
하더라고요. 왜 없냐 그랬더니
자기네들은 낮에만 거래하기 때문에
시차 때문에 안 된다고
>> 어 그러더라고요. 그래서
어 필요하면 연락이나 뭐 이렇게
하는데 어쨌든 근데 그 한국물 자체가
어 [콧방귀] 계속해서 그 미국 쪽에
상장이 되면은 분명히 매수는 어 커질
것 같습니다. 네.
자,이 ADR 성장되면 마이크론하고도
어 멀티플이 비교도 되고 할 건데
>> 예. 어 예전에도 ADR이나 GDR이
미국에 상장이 많이 돼 있었는데 어
결국은 어떤 결과가 나오냐면 어
항상이 차익거래라는 걸 좀 이해를
하셔야 돼요. 차익거래 기회가 존재를
하잖아요. 그러면 해치 펀더들이
하이에나 같이 그 차익거래 기계를
따먹으러 들어옵니다. 그게 옵션,
선물, 휴식 선물, 전환 사체, BW
다 차익거래가
계산을 해서 독사 같은 선수들이
들어오게 되고요. 그러면 예를 들어서
50조 정도의 하이닉스가 상장이
되잖아요. 어 미국에서 멀티플이
올라가면서 우리나라 2,조의 시장을
끌어올릴 수도 있지만 그런 걸 많이
기대를 하지만
>> 어 실제 과거에 GDR이나 ADR이
거래될 때 보면 한국 주식 시장의
평가와 미국의 GDR의 그 차이를
이용해서
>> 음
>> 어 차이거래는 그래서 미국의 GDR이
ADR이
>> 더 비싸지면
>> 미국의 해치 펀드들이 독서가
그거 공
>> 한국 저평가 있는 한국 주식을 사고
>> 예 그러면서 이제 갭이
>> 어 축소되는 그런 모습이 나오고 어
필반 지수 같은데 포함되면서 좀
강하게 매수세가 유입되면서 ADR를
쫙 끌어 올리게 되면
>> 예
>> 공매도를 거기 숏을 잡아도 주가가
오를 거고
>> 예
>> 그러면 거기 숏은 잡고 여기 국내
주식은 롱을 잡아야 되니까 예
그러면서 이제 국내 주식을 거어올
수도 있는데
여러 가지 차이거
일어나면서이
멀티플을
중화시키는 그런 모습도 아마 나오긴
할 겁니다.
>> 자, 시장은 어 왔다 갔다 지금 하고
있고요.
>> 네. 어, 하이닉스 살짝 플러스,
삼성전자 살짝 마이너스 그런 모습인
거 같고 어, 선구 매니저가 만들어
준 그 스팟 프라이스랑 고정거래
가격이랑 어, 그런 거를 가지고
이번에 반도체 매도 타이밍은 어떻게
봐야 되는지 그걸 어제 경제 음,
>> 어제 명지대에서 강의가 있어 가지고
>> 토크 콘서트에서 좀 얘기를 한 부분이
있으니까 아까 어떤 분이 얘기를 해
주셨는데 가서 한번 보시면 아까
청기누 말씀을 드리고 있는데 다음에
또 한번 우리 월관 전망 좀 있으면
월간 전망도 할 거니까 그때도
자세하게 한번 설명드리도록
하겠습니다. 자, 미국 시장 어제 어
유리프로가
살짝 좀 빠질 거 같다. SP 500
빠질 것 같다 했는데 빠졌어요.
>> SP는 빠졌는데 나스닥은 그래도
상승할 거라 했는데 나스닥이 더 크게
빠졌습니다. 어 이게 아까 스페이스엑
때문에 그런 거죠. 그죠? 스페이스.
>> 근데 그 흐름을 본 거는 맞았어요.
>> 오늘은 어떻게 됩니까?
오늘도
스페이스 X 때문에 사실 하락 둘 다
하락할 것 같다라고 생각이 되는데요.
일단 어 내일 마이크론 실적 발표라는
좀 어떻게 보면 치량 자체는 호재로
작용할 것으로 보는 이벤트가 있긴
한데 SP나 안에서 차지하는 비종으로
보면 빅테크들이 더 큰데 스페이스
X가 분위기 자체를 좀 끌고 내려가는
느낌이 있어서 하락을 할 거 같고
그리고 지지선이 그 IPO 스페이스
같은 경우 160달러 정도 됐었는데
이게 지금 깼거든요. 지금 154달러
정도로 이제 마무리가 됐는데
>> IPO 가격은 13
>> 아 했는데 이제 그날 종가 네가
>> 저 종가가 162네
>> 그래서 어 공모가를까지
내려갈지는 좀 지켜봐야겠지만은 내일은
그래도 뭔가 특별한 스페이스가 오를
만한 소재가 없기 때문에 하락하지
않을 거라고 생각이 듭니다.
>> 네. 오늘 밤까지는 하락.
>> 네. 나스닥 SP 둘 다네
>> 필바는 어떻게지
얘기할 때까지만 하더라도 야서 뭐
체결 안 돼 가지고 했는데 저희 회의
끝날 때 야스 체결되면서 좀 분위기
좋아졌었는데 그리고
>> 뭐가됐다고
>> 어 저기 미일이란하고 양해 각서가
>> 아 양해 각서 맞아
>> 예 그래가지고
>> 어 저는 상승으로 하겠습니다.
어 오늘 마이크론이 장 끝나고 실적
발표 장 끝나고 실적 발표인데 내일
모래입니다. 예 우리 시각으로 저
목요일 날
>> 목요일 날 아침에
>> 아침이니까 예
>> 상승세가 이겨질 거다.
>> 예
>> 자 코스피 어제 양봉네
>> 양봉 났나요?
>> 네네 양봉
>> 오늘은 어떻게 됩니까?
어 어제도 말씀드렸지만 마이콘 실적
전까지는 시장이 강할 가능성이
높다라고 생각을 해서 오늘도 낮게
시작해서 양봉날 가능성이 좀 더
높다라고 생각합니다.
양 양봉 어 오늘까지 양봉이고 코스타
어제 음봉이었는데 어떻게네
>> 어제는 연봉 냈어요.
>> 아 연봉으로네
>> 오늘 분위기가 더 음봉으로
가시했습니다.
어, 오늘 음봉.
>> 네. 음봉다.
>> 어, 어제도 음봉 얘기했는데 양봉은
났지만 맞아요.
>> 오늘도 시스템은 계속 음봉.
>> 네. 음봉 유시했습니다.
>> 열평님이 처음에 그 통계 얘기를
하셨는데 그 시작 시점이 달라서
>> 예. 꼬여서 그렇게 나오는 건데.
네.
>> 어, 그거는 저희 제가 다 감안해서
보거든요.
>> 열님 그 통계에다가
>> 플.
정도 하면 왕박사
>> 네
>> 요거랑 거의 비슷하더라고요.
>> 그래서 부담없이
>> 꼼꼼한 성벽이다 보니까 이게 안
맞으니까 좀 감을 가지셨던 거 같은데
열님은 계속 통계를 해 주시면 좋을
것 같습니다.
아 어 오늘도 어 모닝 브리프 자료
준비해 주신 우리 어 직원분들께
감사드리고 어 댓글 형에서도 참
활발하게 많은 얘기들 나눠 주셔
가지고 어 저도 댓글 보면서 그죠
>> 예 도움이 많이 됩니다. 그래서 여러
가지 의견들
올려 주시고
어 시장이 아까 말씀드린 대로 어
녹록 취하는 장이
실력자만 먹는 실적 장소라고 그런
말씀을 드렸기 때문에 저희 채슬리와
함께 아침 모니들으면서
어 때로는 지금이 소외된 종목들 어
사서 물려 계신 분들도 계신데 이번
시장의 특징이 이게
무너지는 시장은 아니다는 거예.
>> 네. 그리고 무너지는 시장이 아닐
수밖에 없는게 어 실적 기반으로
올라왔잖아요.
그리고 반도체 실적이 워낙 좋다
보니까 반도체 지금 쏠림 현상이
심한데 아까 뭐 오과장이 얘기했던
방산도 그렇고
>> 조선도 그렇고 저기 또 빠져 있는
삼형식품 같은 것도 그렇고 어 실적은
괜찮은데 지금 여러 가지 수급적인
부분이나 센티멘트 때문에 그
센티멘트에 [콧방귀]
좀 영향을 주는게 아무래도 아 이번에
연준에서 금리인상 하는 거 아니다.
그래서 22년도에도
1월 [콧방귀] 2월에 어 2월 달에
러우 전쟁도 있긴 했었지만 실제 3월
달에 금리 첫 25bp 인상하고
나서는 3, 4월 달에 반등이 강하게
들어갔었어요. 그죠? 예. 그러다가
5월 달에 25에서 이제 50bp
인상하면서 어 뭐야? 어 금리를
우리가 생각했던 거보다 베이비 스텝이
아니라 어 포켓시하게 올리는 거네
하면서 그때부터 이제 무너져 뜬 거기
때문에 어 오히려 미리 아까 시장이
좀 떨고 있다.
>> 미리 그런 양상이고요. 이번에 금리를
올려봐야 한 두 번 올릴 거예요.
>> 그죠? 올려봐야 한 25p이 한 두
번 정도 올릴 건데
>> 그렇게 보면 이번 조정이 상당히
주식을 싸게 서지는 그런 기회가
된다고 생각하니까예
>> 어 좀 내가 확신이 있는 종목인데
계속 빠지고 있으면 저는
[목을 가다듬음]
>> 계속 키바이 키파잉 하고 그다음에
해야 될 거는 I프레
>> 기도하시고 아스터디 계속 스터디하고
예.
>> 예. 그리고 그 금리나 물가가 지금
약간 상방의 압력을 받는 이유 자체가
22년에는 사실 그 전쟁이 있었기
때문에 코스프시 효과가 있었잖아요.
공급 쪽에 그
>> 차질로 인해서 또 유가가 많이
오르면서예.
예. 물가를 끌어올리는
역할을 했다면 지금은 이제 유가가
조금 완화되는 상황이고 오히려 비트비
쪽에서 케펙스의 증가가 시하게
나타나다 보니까 수요가 견인하는 물가
상승 또는 금리 상승이거든요. 그래서
좀 결이 다른 거 같습니다. 그리
그렇기 때문에 어 더더욱 그 실적이
잘 나오는 어 기업들을 픽해서
가져가면은 오히려 차별에 대한 성과를
내지 않을 수 있을까 싶습니다.
>> 자, 오늘의 클로징 멘트는 키바이
>> 그다음에 키스터디앤
키프레이
>> 예예
>> 기도도 하시고 예 그렇게 투자하시면
될 것 같습니다.네 채슬린 모닝
브리프 오늘 6월 23일 화요일
선서는 여기까지 하겠습니다. 함께해
주신 여러분 고맙습니다.